[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
please
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
please
[Music]
bandai namco
[Applause]
[Applause]
night some good air checking ladies and
gentlemen
everybody to the tekken online challenge
we're in europe when the eastern side of
europe here for the masters event people
have been working their dojo events
collecting points but this right here is
the big kahuna this is the one for all
the marbles the points this one can
really decide who's making those
regional finals i'm one of the
commentators koat said i'm joined by the
legendary abominable how are you doing
my friend thank you very much what a way
to start it lavas privette chin dobre
and bunazuwa thank you for joining us
and i just can't wait to see some
eastern european tekken now i don't get
to play eastern europe's eastern
european players very much and i'm so
excited to see what we've got in store
for us i've watched a lot of matches i
watched evo uh online and i the quality
looks very very strong chaos yeah there
are definitely some names that are going
to stand out like if you watch diva
online there's some of these other
events these the names are really gonna
uh slap you in the face because you're
gonna see them before and you're gonna
see them you know really in their
element now that people have had time to
adjust and adapt we've had a long season
and it's gonna be interesting to see
what happens here today you know part of
our top eight is already done for now
but this tournament would not be
possible that one of our sponsors here
astro the official mix-up and headset of
the tekken online challenge
indeed keeping me very very comfy today
as we talk through the tekken of course
we've had the dojos leading up to now
but this masters event it's a huge
amount of points it's 300 points for
first place and as you work your way
down the points you're still getting
massive chunks so this could really
change the face of the leaderboard thank
you production what a lovely switch and
look at that first place la comey
75 points
fran 70
bitters nikki and then of course an
eighth place a familiar name the evo
online winner for eastern europe lmg mob
i mean lmg mob also he's put himself in
a great position here today he has made
top eight winners side so we'll be
seeing uh some of him later today but he
is someone who is definitely contention
to sort of toppling that bracket uh here
today so like fran for example didn't
make the tournament today unfortunately
the the korean living in hungary uh
unfortunately couldn't make it today so
you know he is someone whose position is
going to be in danger because with
people performing well today you know we
saw it um last week with the west europe
how simply performing well in that one
tournament can skyrocket you into this
top eight and put yourself in a good
position for the regional finals later
on this year
very much so talking from experience
there kwis and of course the comey
number one place he is already out of
the tournament i can already break that
news so that 75 points is going to stay
where it is and then if we look down the
scoring system first place 300 second
place 220 third place 150 he's going to
drop way way down maybe stay in eighth
place but what we do know is we're going
to probably have a new first place
player at the end of today and that is
going to considerably change the face of
the region yeah 110
you know uh we saw we take last week for
example there wasn't really much change
in the top because super cool who was
already on the top with around like 400
points or something like that you know
he won the event himself uh that extra
300 point he's he literally capped
himself on points meaning he is he was
locked in before this one but he's
definitely locked in for the regional
finals uh now at this point so i'm
hoping to see a similar situation here
um and one person you know now that we
can talk i'm super excited to see play
today i don't want to get his game but
it's strong now if you do not know about
stroke this guy
ran at the start of season four
tell you a story how he appeared um it
started season four i i hopped into
ranked one time running to this random
last player no idea who they are this is
before people attack got omega's yet it
was that early season four and i'm just
getting absolutely destroyed by this
last one what the hell is this i said
that's kind of crazy um then the next
day i'm seeing stephie black play this
exact same last play he demotes sephie
black i'm like what the hell next day
doug from paris same thing demote doug
from paris so these are all top european
names who like
have established themselves throughout
the years all getting destroyed by this
random guy and then someone hits me up
like yo this guy's strog top russian
player uh steve and last main has been
around for
a while now in our arsene and he's sort
of helped i think really you know help
put the russian scene on the map and
then um if you pay attention to icfc
players like mickey and um
uh bumblebee these other players 2d girl
we started to see them come out as well
and they really started to see that the
unique russian style which is like very
timing based you know very movement
heavy the way that it's very unorthodox
um so hopefully to see a lot of that
here today it is a treat for the eyes i
must say
yeah the russian dominance of this
region is is clear from looking at at
the leaderboard there's a lot of russian
names on there and uh from looking at
how the brackets progressed we will see
quite a few russian players i mean even
i'm already gonna get into telling old
man stories okay whis but back in the
day i remember playing a tournament
called it um
absolution and there was a guy that
turned up from poland didn't speak any
english whatsoever so from russia
actually and uh he was a bear player
tekken 6 and he absolutely wrecked
everyone apart from one player came
second and it's just that there are a
lot of these regions where you don't
necessarily get to play them because
they're online um but they're so
dominant and they've got so many good
players and i get the feeling we may see
some russian dominance today and of
course there's lmg mob when it went evo
online can't can't uh ignore him but
then there there aren't there were kind
of wild cards in there that you wouldn't
expect of course there's gerlander
playing playing from bulgaria italian
guy but playing playing within the
region and he's looking very strong as
well yeah i mean galada is someone a
name who sticks out to you immediately
when you see a bracket like this um he's
been storming through his bracket had
some great games um some players
actually streaming their pass towards
top pace so good to see some of the
games um but yeah galander looking
strong as always i expected them to have
a deep run here uh yeah people like lmg
mob as well strong
um you know this is this is going to be
a a great day of tekken
and of course there's the polish scene
you can't be under looked as well we've
got why who and you and i commentated
about a breakout performance last year
in the tekken online challenge such a
great great player um and again the
polish style of play i was watching a
polish tournament a couple of days ago
and they said their style is you run up
to someone you stand there you wait you
wait a little bit longer and then you
wait a little bit longer again then you
do it down forward too so i think we'll
be seeing a lot of timing base matches
coming back
like why in a nutshell just do nothing
for a bit and then do something you know
that's that's exactly what we expect and
i think it's crazy at all because um
polish tekken has always kind of been
somewhere at the forefront when it came
to european second i mean uh back in tag
two this is before my time um so i mean
i'm a young boy um but back in tag two
one of the best players in europe devil
i was from poland this was a guy who was
you know destroying everyone on the top
players i spoke to spag a while ago and
he was just like listening to the devil
came back it'd be over for a lot of
these second seven newcomers they'd just
be straight up over
um but yeah you know there's the polish
seat has always been insane i think
tenshi mitsu has then to stay frison as
well um hopefully they've had some deep
runs i've i haven't been able to take a
recent look at the bracket so they could
already be out by expecting some deep
runs from those players as well but you
know the eastern european scene doesn't
get as much shine as western europe but
you know there are players out there
that
you know when you travel because you
know there is a masters event in poland
um which took place of last time in 2019
and when you go out there you just see
how much these guys care for the game
and how you know how passionate they are
and just so how strong their players are
like the replays you've never heard of
before
from these regions just you know
destroying the guys that have come to
travel expecting some free points or at
least
yeah i still i feel like it's 29 it's
been 2019 for the last two years when i
was talking to you before we went on
online you said that that was two years
ago i was like wow really
because we talk we talk about the
offline performances stand so clearly in
our minds they're etched in and that
we've had two years of online nearly uh
i just yeah i just feel like you still
call back to those days and i know that
you know in what in this tournament
we're gonna have some matches early on
that i mean this one for example which
could easily be a final we have had some
matches early on as one we have
struggled going up against hawaii this
right here is a loser's qualifying match
to get into top eight so one of these
two is going home before top eight and i
oh
i i wish both of them could stay but
it's a tournament can't happen like that
this is a heartbreaker for one of these
guys i mean this if you said to me where
what do you see the final looking like
this is one of the permutations that for
me was most likely
this is crazy let's go straight in and i
do have to mention stroke already in
losers break had lost his winners fire
match to lmg mob and from what i've been
told um strog normally wins that game so
that was a big win for lmg mob who is
definitely on the forum after his uh evo
online win but here we go just a very
patient start right now no one's got a
hit yet 20 seconds in
i'll cut i'll cut the bit the first it's
gonna be a big one
it's gonna be a big one
come on
okay
uh i was expecting a bit more but it's
okay um
all right i think we may see a lot of
these k whis these rounds that we don't
see much in the opening seconds as they
try and feed each other out and there it
is down for two count hit strong gets
that combo all day and look at the time
right now you know what's important is
he just builds a life lead right now
because it's gonna be very hard to bring
it back in if anyone can do it is a kuma
bot with eight seconds no meter stroke
is stronger just going to stay down yeah
he can't lose this round
right sure about that right sure are you
sure okay
okay that was that was a stop
yeah i'm interesting first round
well no punish there
oh what a trade they're backbone
obviously going to work out there for
steve what we have to see this matchup
as well is uh
the punish on on fireball you know it's
-14 steve sonic playing is a very long
reaching punish that work most of the
time you have to be careful because if
you do miss face it it's unsafe and when
you go unsafe against akuma you die and
here we go first big combo we might even
get to the wall as well no it's a low
wall splat nice step there from there
very nice nice indeed gonna be a nice
oaky situation don't know mrs the upward
one but running two to take it two
rounds up for stroke already three i've
watched some stroke games recently i've
noticed he's instant running twos they
just never miss and his juggles normally
wow he's he whips that one but his
normal massage juggles usually you'd
nail every single time and we should be
going into the wall with this combo
there it is but no drops the combo
wasn't fast enough regular broken by y
down four and four four four the classic
akuma mix up right there surely we'll
see a lot of abuse of downfall
especially in this matchup as well
i mean what's important against steve is
you know you need those high those high
crushing lows and down through and down
for work a lot of the time that there is
again another downfall um but down three
is a bit interesting because it doesn't
truly high crush there are some highs
that are gonna hit and we saw it right
there that steve back one is really good
for catching akuma when he goes for a
down three uh which is why the the
pakistanis actually use steve quite a
bit as auntie akuma very opposite
oh very nice gets good okay
oh rocket punches that probably had a
sonic fan punished but rocket punch
works there nice combo the rocket punch
again has a life lead albatross down two
and qcf two stroke is definitely in the
driver's seat right now
that game sped up significantly i mean
based on that first round i thought we
were going to be here for a while but
then suddenly it was a race to the face
and they started both of them would get
getting a lot of lows versus each other
and trying to challenge each other to
duck and it just wasn't happening
yeah i mean that's kind of i mean you
see that that game sped up it couldn't
have got any slower than the first round
i mean it took it took 20 seconds before
a jab landed so uh that is that is the
the slowest technology in a while but um
yeah it's kind of what you expect the
russian style noise is very patient um
very timing and movement based and i
think with the character like steve you
know that is someone who can just play
that place out of it to a t when you
play against someone that struggle you
can really you know feel um
just feel his presence when he uses the
character you know every back one is
calculated every down forward too um
that downfall i think that was the first
time i've seen him actually miss the
shiro combo with the massages into the
instant mass 71 so you know he maybe not
his he's not informed today maybe you
know this is there's a day to take out
stroke it is the day but this is the guy
i've really been waiting for
european tekken oh sorry just attack the
world tekken to really see because
stroke has been um absolutely insane
from the moment he first you know
appeared in season four don't know how
long he's been playing the game i've
heard i've heard stories back to second
six second five type two i don't know
um but he is definitely the guy i've
been waiting for the world to really see
he's actually actually um a while ago
actually played online against shadow
20z um they had some sets there so you
know he is he is he's going global um i
i personally no no district lmg mob i
would have loved to see uh strog enter
eva i'd actually win that and have the
chance to go to vegas just to just to
have that like i'm i'm a huge fan of
this guy um and i feel like i need to
stop right now because there's also
another guy playing right now why who's
also pretty good at this game um but
i need to just let everyone know that
strong's good man anyway
i hear i hear you kobe oh i have switch
switz
i've actually never seen why pick geese
in tournament before i've seen him play
the carrots but never in tournament
um and
i can understand the decision you know
steve is good against uh akuma that's
what the pakistanis kind of do like he
plays very well against akuma strog does
well against zakumar so i can understand
but i think
steve also does well against geese
so
i mean i don't know some in situations
like this i'd normally
pick just go with your main character
and tough it out but let's see if the
geese pays off there
i'd agree with you i mean one thing i
did notice is that why was being picked
out of the air very well by stroke and
maybe he was just that didn't feel like
very comfortable actually getting in and
trying to approach him
maybe he'll have better luck uh with
geese and he does straight away with
that power crush
again lots of backing up using that jab
to try and hold them away
both of them waiting for a counter hit
something to get in with
i'm confused my squad is just kind of
ducking
let's pick up there
nice duck as well that's in the down
four four three doesn't actually gel you
even on the hit you can still duck the
second hit great great awareness
punish that thing in there
ten seconds
again are we going to get another
timeout it's looking like strokes round
and it is with the peekaboo down forward
one
switch is a gear just at the right time
strob really in the driving seat right
now again why testing his knowledge oh
big read there didn't didn't work out
stroke just you know a master class
against the 2ds right now being very
patient i'm not sure what this stocking
is about maybe he's really expecting
there's a big back one there i'm
probably probably expecting like a down
four from that kind of range so you know
block that you get launched most of the
time like
i don't know what he's looking for here
but
there's one thing i've noticed about why
when he's winning and he's playing this
style of tekken he looks amazing but
when he's losing it looks like he didn't
really get anything in whatsoever but
here we go and that was a great
opportunity there but just messes up
that's the thing when you're not a geese
main you can mess those things up we
should be going to the wall here it's
going to be big damage i don't know if
it's dead though no it's not
being splat as well
again messing with a lot of
opportunities chases down the bridge
and nice to adjust but look at the time
i don't know if you can do this nice
blocking the down back too needed to
make that read what play from stroke
though to get him out of the air like
that
now i'm back three two
jump on the toes
oh the back one
that is the second time back when it has
and the jab has traded strong's timing
is really on point right now kind of
unfortunate to not get the wall there
but look at this life lead back wide to
the corner just standing there but nice
back three to the 10 year buddy it's
gonna be nice damage as well
gets him all the way over to the other
side doesn't get the splat but still
this puts him in a good position
not that far
but online lows
oh that could have been dead if you got
the pick up for two the low and this
should be the round for why he's having
to take some huge risk just to eke out
these rounds are abominable
yeah he's having to fight really really
hard now and having to come back for
some really sticky situations being
caught in that corner
but here we go again strokes trying to
get all over him the changes in pacing
and timing are really working out at
times for stroke he's finding that that
one more and more
oh now he's finished was waiting for
that all day long knew that a second it
was coming wasn't pulled by it
all right now spending his max mode
we're going to down plus two again
strong is not aware he's not punishing
he's not blocking
he might not know more again
at range
and this is big as well because wires
just built a bar of meter we're going to
carry just shy of the wall here back to
the wall strong needs to do something
rage is available
there
oh my god is it going to be dead unless
he can carry to the wall but with that
nerf wall carry he's not going to get
but run up down 42 we're going to a
final round second game
fight what a start again this could be a
final
and this is this is a set point here for
strong why needs this just to stay alive
but one bar of meter one standing two
one back three two could really change
this entire game oh one down one plus
two sure
feel about one brewing i really do oh
steve can actually punch the second hit
that one plus two again strong is not
ready for this
come back three two
albatross down two
no punish there
no punch right back from why but there
it is count here on the floor we should
be going no drops of the combo that's
not oh that thank you that was it that
was the round that he could have done it
and then
strong
oh my days there it is strong will take
our first game of the day 2-0
over why looking strong calm and
composed that one was that one was
interesting um i know i criticized the
geese figure at first but maybe we went
all the way with it we could have uh we
could have had a final game there who
knows but strong
so strong ready to go and he makes it
into our loser's side top eight and
that's what means we get we get more
strong action for the day which is all
we'd love to see
well i'm sad to see cy go because i
actually he could have killed him twice
over in that final round like he had
that good that juggle which would have
got him an angled wall splat they missed
that then he got him again it was
unfortunate and maybe that comes down to
not picking your main character but as
you say the actual pick of geese look
looked like a good pick you know he was
being punished on all the basic stuff
but he was still getting away with the
the down two he was able to get in and
actually press some offense which he
wasn't really doing so much of akuma so
it was unfortunate unfortunate and it's
real shame to see why go
relatively early for him he still went
far but it was it was early for him i
mean it was it wasn't absolutely stacked
poor i mean i know in that pool there
was the the there was at least lmg
mobile and strong all in that same pool
i mean when you look at those three only
two can make it out it is it is grueling
is is unfortunate someone does have to
go home but you know a great showing
there for strokes he moves into the top
eight um commiseration as to why he will
go home here or stay home at this point
uh just shy of top eight it's one of the
worst positions to be but you know this
is someone who uh will definitely fight
back against that adversity and come
back stronger
onward mentions in that poll as well
boris sonic the talismanic boris sonic
who knows who he used today probably
he's a different character every every
game play marduk earlier was he yeah
i have to check that out just plays a
different there's a every different
character every time you know i think
they first sort of made his name at the
wii player then you know he was sort of
a replacement pick came out of nowhere i
had his first game against arsenal that
was the first game of the event you know
borah sonic vs arsenal that you're
playing with literally top two players
in the world on like the biggest stage
you've ever played on
um so it was great to come out there and
obviously great teams still competing in
these events as well um someone who sort
of like made a bit of a name for himself
so hopefully to see some more of him
he's out of the tournament now this
point isn't either
he is he is another player out of the
tournament that i really wanted to see
tenchimitsu
oh really
yeah i think 10 schmitz and prison were
in the same pool and they said to play
at some point seeing it that was a bit
of a a nationality kill that the polish
team kill um speaking of polish you have
a polish character in tech and now lydia
sobiesko we hopefully will see some of
her here today um but actually right now
we're getting van versus scrabble
destroyer now vaughn from greece i know
as an anna player that's that's the main
character plays anna and link but i
guess um with the recent
uh season 4.2 buffs to lily she has
become a much
more attractive pick to a lot of people
you know i know fergus has been playing
a lot more lily recently carlack has
been committing to lilly rather than
switching through other characters so
you know
vaughn might be enjoying the cat i know
he played lily beforehand um but let's
see uh if uh the buffs have have really
made him ready for the character
straight in with a big low
yeah i like the way you said that as
well attractive more attractive to a lot
of people she's still a very jarring
character to play against no matter
which version of lydia you're playing
against but and again cooney can be as
well there's a lot you have to prepare
for against cooney i mean ron himself
plays game it's later a lot on release
actually uh almost 109 cfc with the
character so he's going to know this
matchup and he's going to be ready for
this
one too no punish you'd have to worry
about that last hitch the hot kick after
set three doesn't work out and we just
shoved the wall here scrap destroyer can
take this first round he does with a set
too
set two i mean what a move it's just so
so good and it makes people really you
have to worry about it and then you can
get in more of set three obviously when
you're playing cuny you do have to go
for those big lows now and again and uh
he actually scuba destroyed managed to
get those in that wasn't really too much
of a problem
oh nice nice steer there from vanda
great block there from scrabble
destroyer
again you're gonna be just shy of the
whole nice run up as well but put it
back to the wall now that's nice
back turn mix no doesn't go for it
to that very patient side stepped away
from the wall very very nice hop kick
see that was actually a read there from
vaughan because that 2 2 2 string that
last his account hit launches so that
was van just expected scrabble to not
finish that last hit and take it very
nice
while standing getting [ __ ] so good
you can see ducking right up in that
grill just getting into while standing
into that full crouch so you can
implement some very very dangerous
mix-ups i mean kidney mister is one of
the best four crash lows in the game
where the full crash downward three hits
from so far away guaranteed forward
forward to sleepy tech roll into a set
back turn mix up you know there we go
with it oh two two this and we all in
the back no it's not minus ten nice
punish there from vaughn back one cancel
down forward one one two three even a
little round punish or a better punish
that was needed and oh my goodness the
dragging
i i feel like that shouldn't have it i
feel like that jump step should have
evaded the rage drive but
unfortunately not
what i liked about that combat though it
was just the tekken fundies come back it
was using the jab using one two applying
simple pressure and he worked his way
all the way back in to get that rage
drive in but here he's grabber destroyed
now again scrabble destroyer doesn't hit
the brakes it's ready to go for a mix of
and smokey in all situations i mean that
was an excellent punish there from five
oh no oh no not the punish you want
there whilst having two is what you're
looking for thereby maybe try a bit too
much for punish that is -11
okay this is looking like van's round
the submissive heel
looking really good right now rage spent
a nice movement there from vaughan takes
the first game and yeah that's why lily
is quite a good character in this game
at this point as well i mean even when
she wasn't fantastic a movement made her
still viable she can step
moves other characters can't or she can
set moves a lot easier than other
characters she can also step things the
wrong way like you know this this tracks
the right side you can't step to the
right lily can and a great movement
there getting around the racetrack and
takes the first game in convincing
fashion
absolutely as a king player i just find
lily's movement and crushing so jarring
and it actually it worked out really
really well the movement in particular
as you said i think van knew that with
his back towards that wall that it made
that rage drive far more attractive an
option to use so almost said okay bring
it bring it on bring it on use that
sidestep so well now i i don't know
scrubber destroyer that well i know
they've got a kunimitsu but i i mean if
they've got another good character i
would consider using it because uh
it felt to me like von knew a lot of the
options a lot of the setups and also
there were some situations where
scrabble destroyer just
overextended just went a bit too far in
trying to implement samoki some big oaky
at that in some situations where maybe
just backing off and waiting to see what
van would do was the better option i'm
assuming if you've played turkum long
enough uh and you're playing kinimit so
you probably have another character um
because that meant for four seasons you
didn't play anyone um so
that's a good point i am assuming
scrabble destroyer will have another
character but um i know i just feel like
rather than the character being the
issue i feel like some bad decisions
were made i mean
he did i don't i didn't see many set
twos when he did go for set two it
worked out
so what that what that's telling you is
van is ducking a lot of the set mixer so
that's your that's your uh license to
just go for set mids um i myself have
lost feel there's no real scary option
and set to make you not want to duck and
when she does do set three the slide
that is launched punishable so you know
it's more attractive to to duck that uh
in those scenarios so it'll be
interesting to see how he adapts to that
but you know go to the infinite stage i
don't know if i like this decision
especially against lily
yeah i'm with you on this i mean you
just talked about set two that
ridiculous move has it tracks one way
has wall splat
massively puts on here not punishable on
block i mean that takes some of the
benefits of that move away but okay
let's see if it pays off that was nice
they're doing the empty set to ask
anyone like i said was seeing that van
is ducking and that's actually not the
punishment down three is only minus 12
not 13. whilst i don't want shouldn't
have hit
no punishment while selling three i
don't know if cuny has a long-range
punishment probably the kunai would work
out but look at this already a better
start here for scrabble destroyer maybe
the infinite stage is the play
[Music]
why i don't know
that that's the part i think maybe
sometimes your favorite stage is just
your favorite stage that's it it's just
your favorite stage
i mean that's one thing i've found is
sometimes stage fixtures can be also
just a mental thing you play better on
this stage you enjoy the interviews
enjoy dance right now and like lily has
great movement couldn't you mix who has
one of the best back dashes in the game
so it's not uh exactly a horrible pick
but great hot kick there from vaughn
didn't want to respect the bat turn
mixed up at all
broken
one one in rounds now
night and day with the last game both of
them getting in a lot more trying to
employ an offense oh not quite close
enough to get that with punish and
scrabble just going for the raw mixes
right now what if the step three didn't
work out then dash here what's the
wildlife three it looks like scrabble
destroyer just wants the mix-ups right
now but our hop-kick von does not care
right now
roots of evil
no punisher in the back to the mid is
-10 you have to down jab it
let's grab a destroyer looking to get
that in
trying to catch up down four two one
incoming i know
okay this is the start oh great block
there from
scrabble destroyer just flying too close
to the sun
i don't mind it though he put himself in
a situation where raw 50 50 would get
him the win
and uh sometimes that pays off sometimes
it doesn't now he's got to fight his way
back that was a great float there from
john i mean what was seeing scrabble is
game plan has turned into it's just
mixed up i'm gonna end your face i'm
gonna duck full crest down for three or
while standing on the while standing
three that's all it is right now nice
usually one plus two doesn't get
anything though two two
oh messes up the full crash downpour
through that oh and the load no launch
though from vaughan and but there it is
the qcf three plus four takes it van
moves into our top eight uh scrabble
district unfortunately is gone but you
know i feel like vaughn just had their
game in the bag from the beginning you
know when you when you saw how scrabbled
the straw was playing it just all came
down to the 50 50s i'm trying to mix you
it just looked like vomit was in
driver's seat and when you when you're
making your opponent well you're forcing
your opponent to play that kind of
playstyle i think you've already won the
game from there yeah i'm with you i
think one of the things i noticed that
scrabble destroyer was doing was he was
do you know when you're playing a guy
that you've never seen before and you're
like okay i want to test if you know
this i want to test if you know this and
you start reading off your menu of
setups that will just like bag you a
good a quick win it felt like he he
really maybe should have shown run a bit
more giving him a bit more credit and
known that actually he will know a lot
of these setups irrelevant of whether
he's a cooney player he's a top top
player and i think he actually lost a
fair few rounds trying out these cannon
setups when he probably should have just
tried to play
a more safe game but still massively
enjoyable to watch did go far in the
tournament
and let's have a look what we've got
coming up in the future on the tekken uh
online challenge because if this is a
truly global tournament and tomorrow
we've got the west african tournament i
can't wait to see african tekken i feel
like this is the net going to be the
next breakout region after pakistan and
that's tomorrow i know what i'm doing
tomorrow yeah i'm actually commentating
that event so i cannot wait to just you
know see all that uh the actions go down
uh one play i'm really excited to look
for and that one is uh she's skywalker a
very strong law player from ivory coast
who uh you know spag says one of the
best laws in the world
um which is
is high praise as well especially
concerning the amount of people who
played that character as well um yeah he
is absolutely insane someone i'm looking
forward to see play in that event um and
seeing if anyone can actually take him
down because he'd been on a bit of tear
over there because you know uh next week
sorry the week after you know south
africa middle east south asia southeast
asia you know it is like city is truly
global and then obviously korea and
japan are mastered again and then
starting uh in november when the
regional finals will begin um and yeah
that's where you the this is what
everyone's playing for you collecting
these points for those events there um
and a good performance
here today uh can really make sure you
cement yourself in those regional finals
uh in the case of this region i think
this masters event you know the top five
players are likely to be in that final
top eight and so far based on the
quality of tekken we've seen that makes
for a very exciting final um and of
course that encourages everyone to get
their dojos going as well i mean if you
if you don't want this masters to be the
deciding factor get those dojos going
let's get some uh local dojos in place
and uh jeff just such good tekken i'm
really excited to see what i've got and
that top eight is already firming up to
be very exciting especially with
galander waiting in there that wild card
to see what he can do as well yeah and
i've been i mean some of the regions as
well you see the regions have like the
most points without through through
other players i think that's west europe
and north america um because there's a
lot of uh of icfc's taking place and
those are dojo events the second online
challenge so those are you know
um tournaments running weekly uh 100
plus players so you know that's why
there's so many points spread out
throughout those regions as well so
you're really seeing that people just
running your dog like you said get the
dojo is good because you know people one
of those regional finals are yeah
there's no joke there's a lot of money
up for grabs at those events well and
obviously you know the pride of uh
competing well on those big events it
really does mean a lot to so many
players so make sure you guys uh compete
get involved you know this is this is a
for everyone it's a truly global uh
second online challenge this year it
absolutely is and of course everyone has
an opportunity to have a breakout
performance no matter whether it's a
dojo or anything else there's so many
opportunities to get some big points i
mean the tekken were world tour the
original offline second world tour there
are a lot of players really placed quite
high because of their dojo performances
in their local region there was that
opportunity to do that um and yeah i
mean and those players have gone on to
actually pick up bigger wins later on
down the line online and one thing i've
noticed with tekken 7
in particular compared to the other
tekkens
is that there are some top top players
who
learnt tekken just in tekken 7 which is
actually quite different to a lot of the
other tekkens normally if you found like
a really great player in tekken tag 2 or
tekken 6 it was likely that they've been
playing for the last three or four
seconds but this game's been really
inclusive um and there's loads of new
players that have come through that are
showing so much talent and ability and
when they come offline from the online
scene they're going to tear things up
yeah i think second seven is the second
that has been the most accessible to
getting for you know one of the best
players in europe right now chicken
mario started in 7-7 and that was the
game he he started in this game and
became one of the best players in europe
by by the like this year at this point
so you know it's insane uh to think like
that but we have our next game right now
right now we have ukraine good up
against turkey we have oligino against
um and this is an interesting match
right here [ __ ] run versus uh uh
thing that's our first [ __ ] rum of
the day
this character is still a bit
controversial with the tekken spaces not
many people like him i don't myself but
um yeah this yeah let's see how this one
works out
both of them have the ability to bust
through this stage as well pretty
quickly be interesting to see if they go
for that
i mean i think as a character as well
very recently a lot of people have been
um been talking about a lot of people
have been playing him jerusalem picked
up the character recently joker in
europe i've been doing a lot with the
characters so and let's see what our
harmony thing can do with the character
nice block there on the qcf one develop
a bigger punishment there it is
the guard don't want that to happen
i mean feng has very good options to
beat a lot of the guard races back one
here he has his shoulder he has things
that can i mean speaker the shoulder
great punish there with back to one
excellent there from oligina great start
that shoulder it's one of those moves we
all know it's launch punishable but it's
it's still jarring and sometimes you
miss it but he was ready straight away i
mean you rarely ever see a [ __ ] run
player punished with back two one and
that situation just very smart very
controlled no launch there a lot of
[ __ ] those are very punishable so you
have to take advantage of that that
could be a great damage for her major
thing
step four tries to get cheeky
there's that punch the back he should no
doesn't do the correct comfort does
downpour one two instead of one two one
do you think he's a bit more worried
about doing kenpo against backhand run
because of the range he can operate at i
wouldn't be worried about that side step
four because this should break it next
to the round four leggy that was
oh boy
right there just breaks the floor like
that okay
i like that he's still go he's still
trying to control the game he's losing
two rounds to zip but he is actually
trying to put the offense on and control
the game and that's good for there from
hamid can get the break to the floor
very nice
he really needs to make something happen
here he needs this round a nice back
turn throw makes up that's it hamida's
on the board
and what a statement as well manages to
get that perfect hope for him he's
hoping that's a momentum shift no more
flaws to break
still trying to get in there
great use of three plus four there's the
track down back kemp in the knife but
he's interrupting now after the three
four four and nice you know what that
was a great adjustment there from
allegheny excellent adjustment back to
three this time oh and
move but that shouldn't happen
but ah the three one takes and only
takes the first game so um i just have
to say that was quite a great adjustment
there from aleguino we were seeing him
do the three four four which is the plus
six a plus six high kick that's your
launcher are on hit he was doing that a
lot into jet kick which isn't a frame
trap there's two frames to interrupt and
hermes just started he was jabbing that
every single time so what again instead
of just do standing three off these plus
six stands through complete frame trap
there's nothing you can do about it so
that's a great adjustment there um and
that adjustment there also ended up
winning him the game because then he
went for uh the guard break which for
some reason tracked him when he tried to
sidewalk which is what you're supposed
to do against the guard break but i
don't know unfortunate on this day
um yeah unfortunate but i do feel like
uh the the stage was in fact's favor
there so maybe a stage which is in order
yeah well sometimes when if that movie
even though that movie is steppable
sometimes the walking work against you
and do some pretty odd things and i
think that might have played a played a
part in that case but one thing i liked
about aleguino is that
i'm just so used to playing against
vacuum rams who are just
like cajones deep [ __ ] rams that are
just trying to test your knowledge of
every single situation he wasn't always
doing that he was actually trying to
play a defensive punish focus back and
ram and and um hamid actually got quite
a lot of offense in and i quite enjoyed
seeing someone trying to back up and
focus on punishing properly with
punishing and hamid has changed over to
paul
on that cave of enlightenment
interesting pick
i don't think the fan pick was that bad
he was doing okay he was pressuring he
was putting some damage in it was more
his own knowledge of hackerman that was
letting him down
i think both characters as well they're
odd
i feel like paul is also a good pick
against falconrom though you know thing
like you say it more came down to his uh
his match up in familiarity which is why
he lost rather than the character
because there are things that fan could
do really well in this matchup those are
things that paul can do really well in
this matchup so the cv knows i mean okay
never mind because he starts off with a
classic frame trap there and straight to
the one that's half of your life gone
for me so
oh okay nice nice to hit confirm it
doesn't work out again he's still doing
the same setup
three one down four three one down four
again down for herme just doesn't know
this matchup
he was trying to get his stuff in
there's no doubt about that again starts
off the round with buttons trying to get
his stuff in but other guinea he's got
he's just got more complex stuff to
deliver than what happens offering one
more one plus two blake not the uh here
we go
nice down jump to interrupt there
there's back into the breakable
jet kick but it's a trade it's not the
worst situation in the world back three
goes under two throw not broken i like
it
side stepping trying to get reverse the
situation three one down four again okay
let's parry's this time gonna spend the
range off because he can cancel it okay
let's see what you make a count you have
to make this count make it count
oh and they're just three or four that
time
just three one four
questioned the council i think it was
actually was decent damage it's just his
decision making on the on the oath he
was a bit off i mean the problem is
three one down four is launched
punishable it's like -16 minus 17 so you
know yeah launching every single time um
but what he needs to start doing is
first off not get here by jet kick uh
and second he needs to start ducking 3-1
and then punishing because you know he's
just getting
destroyed by mix-up back to charge and
this is going to be the route
yeah there is lagina will take that 2-0
pretty fast over hamid um
yeah just
match up and finally all over the place
didn't know what he was doing and i
think in that situation back to one hit
is a very scary situation to be put in
because the only way to make that charge
whiff after back two and hit is to
interrupt you have to match and some
people aren't ready to push a button
after just getting hit so it's a very uh
annoying situation we put in but just
like that arduino takes it moves into
our top eight and hamid i think can
hopefully go down the the [ __ ] run
match up because that was that was
painful to see
he's represented his region well he went
far um it's great to have a turkish
player nearly make it into the top eight
we don't see enough turkish tekken yeah
i think
it's very clear
hamid went far in the tournament i mean
he he's obviously there were a lot of
matchups he did know well uh and [ __ ]
webster is a problem to a lot of players
and he just was a heavy problem for him
then i would have liked to have seen the
thing uh stay he just seemed so much
more confident pressing on offense with
feng and it you know he got the perfect
in the the first game he also took a
fair bit of damage in the rounds he lost
i think there was still some more damage
to be done there and fortunately that he
decided to go with the pool
um i think you know we see it all the
time if you switch your character you
are going to be switching to a character
you're likely less confident with even
if it's the right pick on paper
i mean yeah i mean i i think of the two
thing it's still a very good pick and
judging by his name hamid thing is
probably the main character so i think
just stick out uh we're playing maybe
pick a different stage that could have
maybe won the game unfortunate but um
yeah hamid will go home and again moves
on into our top eight but next up we
have prison
uh with the leroy disappointing you
prison where's your steve uh good up
against axe swan this is someone i've
never heard of before from from greece
um i know greece is a very strong
technician the two top players normally
always stand out arvad and uh nivik back
in 2019 when everyone's traveling those
two were doing everything
all over the place you know came to the
uk went to went to poland uh never
keeping going all the way to combo
breaker making top 24 over there so
uh axe was a player i haven't heard of
from the from the grease seats i'm
excited to see what they do thank god to
make us so let's see
uses it straight away in the first round
you don't see that very often
prison he did pick uh leroy back when we
did take an online challenge on the um
the second day with the friendlies and
uh
he looked did look very strong with him
i mean i always want to see his steve
it's god look weak with leroy and nice
that is true
back one plus two the 123 mid count here
launched a great start here from prison
goes from makes up straight after very
nice into the orbital nice step
that's one right now down four four
three and nicely upward one tries to
interrupt doesn't work out axl
time to push your advantage messed up
the ford ford four though unfortunate
one of the okay
i think we're gonna see more that up
forward one it's looking very strong but
here we go prison two rounds up straight
away
yeah great start
there we go again nice
hell sweet can you see another one
he knows the combo from here very nice
down three doesn't finish it but the
back one plus two and prison is going to
take that first round
pretty fast i have to say that was not a
slow game
he's play he's playing like he's got a
train to catch that was unbelievable
that was quick on a wall of stage on a
wall of stage as well that that is hella
quick both of them were just looking to
get their stuff in jab into orbital but
to be fair there were some of those
canned setups but then the side stepping
was absolutely beautiful and the ability
as well to parry some of the sword stuff
because you know not many players can do
that and it does change the match up
quite a bit
yeah i mean noctis is a character that
doesn't normally have to worry about
being paired very often because your
stuff like his 2-2 which is you know
very easy it's a two-hit string mid-mid
um it gets it has mix-ups after it has
two two four two or two-two into the
rest of the string and against lyra you
have to worry because that black two
parry is gonna is able to parry
everything including weapons uh elbows
knees things that shouldn't
traditionally be able to be parried in
seconds so
you know it's so that was a great start
there from prison it looks like leroy
was the good pick i i feel like steve is
also good against noctis so if you want
to switch characters as you always can
but um yeah and i saw electing to keep
the infinite stage as well um
i kind of i like noctis with walls to be
honest i think he does quite well with
them um i don't think leroy is
particularly strong with walls in play
as well that could be a bit even but i
guess he wants the space to move around
and sort of avenge his infinite loss
look at this beautiful
transition there we go and we go
straight prison with a double one
down back
here
that's it too
again that was a great float there by
axel we're gonna go for four four four
yep watch the okay here you have to get
right prison
it's fine he'll take that here all day
[Music]
life deficit oh no that could have been
a great whiff punish there no punisher
on the r43
oh again run upside sidestep that works
so well just that afford one is so quick
and it would cover so quickly nice light
this could be the right if he knows the
combo yeah that's it
even though he has quite a bit of health
left that's gonna be dead there for
prison nice work there from axl gets
[Music]
both of them just playing so quick again
button straight away
nice one is getting going now
nice float nice combos boys is aware
all right the two two back two is
instead of the ford ford four one's
gonna go for damage instead
i wanna get the counter here very nice
pick up there from prison he's aware
[Music]
oh but one plus two counter hit this
could be the round no he has another
correct combo
but one more here does it here down back
through very nicely frisian try to get
up and push a button there after that
ender it is not your turn noctis gets to
keep the pressure going
i love that for maxwell just going for
the jabs in the jungle at this stage in
the tournament at this stage in the game
interesting choice oh but there's the
orbital prison going for the
the early nero combo there
he's going to max damage back one count
now board 1-1 prison isn't out of this
yet
never a bad option at this stage of the
round
both using the tools that have helped
them out in this game so far back one
plus two count hit going for the new
combos as well four four three i like
how he ends commas with four four three
to go for a helmet mix up
oh wait a second
does that go over a dick jab and you
still got the the launch
okay
oh again and he's nice awareness to know
he can still get the combo from there
that isn't consistent what's the other
most people would try and punish and get
counted here launched
this mike no that's dead yeah that's
dead 110
i am never wrong about these things
very nice start
i actually got buffed in season four to
go to from 14 frames to 13. went for the
background catch didn't work out
oh my gosh down three two isn't just
trying to be annoying right now we're
trying to poke it back into this game
four two three nice finishes the string
finishes it tries to punish too early
that's what that two-two string is about
all about
oh
tries to whiff punish doesn't work out
this is going to give frizzen away back
into this game what's the oaky spring
kick range
ray dressed by axel 20 seconds left one
one punish him he doesn't oh
[Music]
that was cheap
that that was cheap
no i i have to be honest that was cheap
that was cheap frizzy did one one one
plus two which is minus ten
and then he went for there's the bag
that's cheap
that's gp's for you clutch factor that
that's cheap factor
he did unsafe into parry that's cheap
that's that's not fair okay let him get
one too much he didn't he didn't even
jab he didn't do one two two he didn't
punish he did down for one instead um
and i think that new tobacco pack two is
actually minus ten and blocked so if
axel blocked her and punished that could
have been dead so it was a risk that was
taken but i still think it was cheap at
the end of the day um
but yeah it was a great game though what
a game that was that was that was that
was
everything everything just uh altered
i'm just throwing out there now that is
frison our final player that makes it
into our top eight and i believe we have
our top eight bracket ready to look at
and it's all shiny and pretty and there
it is at the top we have lmg more going
up against
greetings uh exceeds the land they're
going up against bumblebee strobe versus
vaughn and prison versus olegino and
these matches if you guys have been
paying attention today you will see
that every one of these matchups is
amazing i'm the person i'm most
surprised in this topic right now is
actually her greetings uh that was
somewhere she saw uh compete uh in and
out of icfc when it was uh the entirety
of europe had actually not had the best
performances so this is a real break out
here right now get up against lmg mob
probably that's that's probably the
favorite to win it in my opinion uh
based off evo but my
i'd say the true favorite is strong
that's just me being biased that's a
true favorite to win um but anyway on
your plays like galander bumblebee
the [ __ ] run player this one is going
to be if you have to pick one person
right now to do who you picking to take
it all the way
it's it's the guy that's rolled into
eastern europe in a trojan horse
gurlander
he's going to break out of that horse
and just smash everyone up
i'm obviously joking here i think
olander looks very strong i mean the guy
you just can never rule him out of any
tournament ever like he he he goes very
far his knowledge is impeccable he's
played in many different regions he's
lived in the uk
played there obviously played in italy
now he's playing in eastern europe
he's a he's a really really strong
player and he's already proved that he
can beat absolutely anyone
i think strog might turn it on i i
actually watched his games versus nmg um
in in the pools and he won the first
four rounds so
decisively it was unbelievable and i
think he if he gets on a roll uh he he's
just going to be very very strong and
hard to beat i mean yeah glad is that
probably i'd say the guy if you've been
watching international tech for a while
now you'd say it's probably going to
take it the guy who's you know uh the
2018 lcq winner um all the way back then
so definitely someone who knows how to
how to win a tournament um we also have
something special for you guys to see uh
right now you ready stream gently look
at this much officially licensed second
merchandise uh the good ass tekken uh
turno media uh got the officialized
attacker these are limited got the law
in the lore colors the black and yellow
the bruce lee colors very nice as well
these are these actually ran out of
stock very fast so make sure you guys uh
pick these up very very very very very
fast uh scanner qr code gold uh i'll go
to 100.g.g4
merch so just pick one of these up
because they are nice and also above all
you like that right
i love it i've actually ordered the king
shirt i ordered it a week ago i was
hoping it would be here so i could wear
it today and instead i'm not but i'm
when i get this i'm gonna i'm gonna wear
it every day i love it i'm gonna change
it to i'm gonna get a post-it note
though and slap it over the the second
word and change it to us because i'm
british and uh as far as i'm concerned
it's good arse tekken
uh but yeah look at that look at that
king shirt it's beautiful absolutely
beautiful
my shirt's in copenhagen right now i can
tell you all so if anyone's in
copenhagen please intercept it and get
it to me quicker i can't wait to get it
i'm gonna meet them halfway instead of
waiting
and of course follow us online at bnee
esports on twitter and on youtube and
there's a tekken twitter tech and twitch
and tekken facebook please do check them
all out make sure you guys consume all
of the tech in action uh that you can
because you know this is this is you
know we've got the technology challenge
running uh until the end of the year
because obviously we have the dojo
events the regional finals so uh the the
masters eventually what we're seeing
he'll be running until at the end of
next month and then the regional finals
will start in november so make sure you
guys uh just just get involved follow
all the socials um to make sure you
don't miss out on any of the tech and
action we've got coming for you guys
and now we're going to go to a break but
do come back very soon we have top eight
waiting for you and every match is
looking like it could be a final
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
enemy warships
[Music]
arrive to destination
[Music]
enemy reinforcements check your radars
so
[Music]
[Music]
lobster
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
i've been waiting a long time for this
so this is what it's like to be a super
saiyan god
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
what is up everyone welcome back to
tekken online transform that is right
goku is coming to season five that is
that that that's it right above them all
that's happening
who's goku
i don't know what you're talking about
don't do this again
do not do this again anyway we are back
uh the tekken online challenge also a
huge shout out to astro the official
headset makes up of the technolon
challenge 2021 war astroduck they'd love
to support tekken we appreciate them for
that so
we are here this is the top eight let's
take a look at the top eight
i'm i'm breezing through this i love it
but yeah so here's our top eight bracket
for um
our toc today um and yeah lmg mob um i
think is someone who is definitely i'd
say probably like you say golan's people
i'd say this is the guy who's the
favorite because for me going to this
one stroke was a definite favorite uh to
win the whole thing and i think lmg was
the guy that put that put strong into
losers so he is definitely in a good
position uh her greetings uh actually
took out scrabble destroyer the the the
kilimitz we saw earlier to make his way
to top eight um galander actually had to
be frison
um so you know these guys they're
already in good good shape they've
already beaten some top players get to
the point where they are now and
obviously strawberries is fine down
there and frison versus olegino i mean i
think bumblebee actually beat olegino to
to make his way into top 8 so that's
actually a big statement as well because
we saw how strong that [ __ ] ram was
earlier so this is going to be
an amazing top a abominable indeed
allegheny looking like he could play
offense and defense uh with [ __ ] ram
so i mean every single player there
i remember the good shout and you and
you're right i mean lmg mob must be
hearing me so to talk about garlando and
you talk about stroke saying hang on a
minute guys i'm in winners
i just want evo online
surely it's got to be me and you can't
really argue with it you can't argue
with it at all the guy is hard-working
he seems knowledgeable he plays a
character that hasn't been uh at that
top tier or isn't isn't that that top
tier now but obviously he's a lot
stronger in season four um and yeah he's
looking in a very very prime position to
go all the way i mean a lot of the
character who got you know a big suite
of buffs in season four and i think the
main thing it did was just give him
absolutely insane wall carry you know
he's able to carry from wall to wall
most stages and it's pretty good and
it's also the fact that um
uh sorry i was gonna say strong again
like i like this is what you talk about
ellen jordan has some very unique combo
roots himself some very hard technical
combos so very unique combos so it's
gonna be interesting to see how um you
know how he because he is someone who
probably was was laughing when when he
saw those last pass because his combos
were really good and before before
season 1 is like you just made me
stronger but we have to forget about him
for now because up but next we've got
gallander up against bumblebee and
gallant is still rocking that katarina
who um back in season three a lot of
people said katarina is dead she is done
for uh season four got a few boss record
down for one is kind of right a new low
from harrier so let's see
uh if gallander can take advantage of
that going up against kunimitsu in
bumblebee i did wonder about gurlando
obviously we know him as playing cat but
he plays so many different characters
he's got a phenomenal king as well i was
kind of expecting genre from
yeah
oh nice stuff
great aggression
that's something there's a bumpy just a
very very aggressive in your face game
plan but all late on the punisher and
down forward see
if bomb will begin he's very hard to
stop a nice whiff punish there from
galander he's all that lars will carry
earlier we're going to see him katarina
wall carry just shy there
i mean all all glad need is one naught
to go to all but nice nice down before
that beats the one one two great start
from bumblebee
good knowledge there from bumblebee
yolanda already having to fight his way
back afford four four punish nice
i'm glad someone told me bumble's name
was bumblebee before because before i
used to say boom boom boom right that's
that's what i thought the name was until
someone said no that's that's bumblebee
i was like oh okay
no break from the one throw there
finishes it again nearly
oh nice guaranteed stomp there very nice
there from galander great start and one
launch to the wall he will win this
round
this katarina's race drive is kind of
crazy it is and he's looking for it but
now he is at the wall
nice we're punched with the two two
oh and the set three good land looking
for a down back three there a bit risky
didn't work out i'm being prime position
right now
now the walls are taken away
oh but nice
firm there from boom boom boom
garlander is in a real pickle right now
looking like he's in big trouble yeah
and the set two catches the spring and
that's gonna be the round here for pump
will be and that was just so stylish i
feel like
tekken players if you can end away
stylish like that just do it all the
time please it just looks nice um anyway
great option what a good option as well
finishing with that and
wow that went quick
galander needs to change it up big time
and you know i don't we've played a lot
of galander the character is never going
to be the problem he will need to adapt
to the player and what the opponent's
doing i think what i'm just seeing him
more than anything he just
he's not playing against kunimitsu
very well um which is a bit obvious to
say losing down losing a 3-0 but like
he's just you know stuff like two two
two he's not ducking the third hit he's
just taking the string he's waiting for
the last hit you know the cartwheel uh
kilimanja is down four three plus four
which is such a such a strong neutral
controlling tool she can go into back
turned into or stay in front of you you
kind of really can't really react to it
and then she has the back turn mix up or
stays in your face i think she's
actually plus i think it's minus two um
which isn't even that bad for kuni mitsu
you know she has stuff like 4-1
um which is jails both hits high tracks
to a weak side like uh glenda just isn't
playing around any of this really well
um you know i one thing i like that he's
doing is when bumblebee approaches in
set he is ducking most of the time like
i said earlier there isn't really a mid
you should really be scared of in set
maybe block the set three you get a full
launch so it's worth the risk uh in my
opinion
um but other than that he's just he's
he's come close he's come close taking
some rounds but bumblebee has just
managed to clutch out uh every single
time so you know we're going to see some
adaptations here from galander and i
like it it's also random select he he
knows exactly it was just the way he was
playing in that game it wasn't the
character it wasn't the stage's fault he
just needs to make some adaptations and
i think he's ready for it
we will find out golana does need to
change it up he probably needs to slow
down ever so slightly as well and to
think that bumblebee won that three-nil
and didn't really need to put in any
full crouch mix-ups at all didn't need
to go big didn't need to go too big
anyway i just needed to see galander
pull out that brick wall because bumpy
like i said earlier is someone who
wanted when he's on the front four when
he gets going as all the momentum in his
favor is very hard to stop and you see
here trying to get going we need to see
we need galadas to force bombi to play
defense but that's not going to happen
in this round anyway
oh i like it drops the combo early
because he didn't want to put uh
gallander in rage
nice choice there is the two two two and
atlanta tries to challenge after that
and bumpy four rounds straight right now
looking the much stronger player right
now in this particular matchup goodness
the two string just the option selector
the jump over the battery
one will be there everything's working
out
okay this should be a start here for
galander
again not ducking the two not ducking
the third hit
this is poor right now for galander but
not the best will punish their single
hop kick
and the down forward four bumby five
rounds straight right now galanda
doesn't know what to do
is this gonna be a double no round round
no galander needs to change it up this
is a good start
exactly what you need we need to see
gollando force bumby to play defense but
just to messes up the combo there and
now look back to the wall almost in the
corner full crash down four three what's
the follow up two two
two it's not the worst first full crash
down four three in the whole game as
well it's gone
oh my face in the earlier the cartwheel
the down four three plus four just like
that bomb we would take it six rounds
straight
over gallander that was just a kuni
mitsu master class right there and golan
milan is not done yet we've had a lot of
loser matches but this is our first
winners match of the day so glenda will
just move down into the losers bracket
but you know bumblebee moves on into the
winners final
don't rule gallander out i know what
he's doing right now he's going straight
into p mode and he's working out what he
did wrong
and and i think you called it i think
not handling 2-2-2
and the continuation of it was a real
problem i mean i i get it it it's even
if you duck the high it can be
problematic to know exactly what your
best button will be you know on paper
it's a launch but then there's problems
getting in between the next hit there's
all sorts of issues there but it looked
like he was pressing buttons and that
just wasn't the option i mean the your
best thing to do is just just duck the
third here and then just do a quick
while sending four that's what you
should be doing yeah at one point
galander tried to duck it and then do
full crouch down for four which would
have worked but that's the time she
decided to do the other option the
teleport out of there instead which is
what makes the mix up so annoying she
doesn't have to finish the string she
can do the teleport instead of trying to
option select that she's out of there so
you know unfortunate
um
glenna moves down into the lower bracket
but you know bumblebee looking very
strong right now and i'm if i'm mobbing
greetings and be looking at like that
okay i hope my kinemaster knowledge is
ready because even though when this this
game bumby's looking very strong right
now
yeah i mean how good is kunamitsu as
well like i
look i've looked down the character
quite a few times now and i've just been
baffled by the number the various
different layers and levels that she can
be played at like that down forward 3-2
cancel into a while standing move that
is very very hard to to react to um the
mental frame she can play with with all
of her long strings there is so much
that she can do and her throw game which
shouldn't be
overlooked either the
the throw that she walks up you like i
always press two because i'm thinking of
law yeah i mean i get it wrong uh could
it be a superstar game cannot be ever
said even the one through if you break
it one which puts her leg up uh she can
kind of get a back turn mix up on you
because you're both back and she can do
like a down four if she expresses down
four she can do like a the flip the back
the back turn flip over like she has a
lot going for us so you've got you know
uh also the back 10 throw mix such as
one plus two or regular throws so yeah
like the throw mix up she's he's a
pretty good character to come this game
uh so late
and i think um she's just gonna continue
to give people issues especially i think
especially if you're not ready for the
match up which uh it just looked like
gallander wasn't um she can just run
over you like that you have to the one
that's kind of prepared for going into
especially with some of that bumblebee
you just when that aggression gets going
impossible
very hard to deal with and we are
straight into our next game we are
rocking through this tournament and it's
been a feast for the for the eyes so far
really really strong players and get in
got a king player absolutely i think
i've i've wanted this so bad i love king
plays on top eight
really just excited to see cake i mean
i'm excited to see lmg mob this is the
guy the evil online eu east champion you
know the person who everyone else in
that top four he was the guy to put them
in to lose he defeated every single one
to move forward so
um i said before evil i was the person i
was seeing evo online eve our worst he
compete was strong and we didn't see
strobe compete in that so for me that
was me saying okay if strogan said he
could have won but lmg more beat strong
today put stroke into the loser's
breakfast so
let's see but her greetings you know
rocking that king i know you're excited
wave dashing with king straight away
instant uh shiny wizard i'm liking what
i'm seeing straight away back to four
um yeah this this is looking like a
strong king already nice back one two a
nice stuck in punish there from mob
we'll not be able to break the wall he's
going for the fancy stuff oh
yay oh but the hot knee
this could be the route no comp no
balcony that wasn't oh wait would this
work he's gonna be airborne oh he did
what
that was a punish
that was absolutely crazy
i was going to say he was unfortunate
enough to get that wall break but then
it all worked out pretty well for him
yeah and that that count three was
actually a punish on the rage jazz and
great block uh great throw break there
from uh nmg mob he needed that nice ball
for neutral too
oh what a duck
oh bad punisher as well the forward
water option is that very nice trying to
go for a hardcore it doesn't work out
always go for the mix up there that's
what i like about mob doesn't always go
for max damage but catches mob ducking
what's the follow-up the alley kicks
greetings with a great start right now
look at the way i love it
did it back to in the previous round
then went for a two-throw after he got
ducked and launched for that time he he
mixed it up the last music has started
the final round last music has started
when you pick this outfit here we go
down back four count hit is powering up
this is it he needs the music gonna do
some fancy stuff here whilst anyone nice
blocking punishment nice
cancel it new slash it's very nice there
from mob we should be going to the wall
yes we are shoulder can he take this
round with the music power up oh no down
four two count him unfortunately
he's a side step yeah
this isn't dead
what a start there from greetings to i
know i know you love that talk talk
about talk to people what you saw there
i i'm really happy with what i saw like
there were there were a bunch of things
in there that i loved good punishment on
the minus 13 uh move and
a memory of what the opponent did
straight after some previous moves so
when he did that about one two went into
the two break got launched with a while
standing one he said okay i remember
what he did last time this time i'm
gonna go for a forward three just frame
and there was lots of tough technical
stuff that he was doing in there um that
i was really surprised with i mean
that's not a pocket king that's a fully
developed rounded king and it's looking
very strong
yeah definitely the perfect start there
against someone like mob as well you
know people probably looking at mob as
the
the name to take i thought this is the
thing uh when you win a huge tournament
in the the same way that mob did you put
a target on your back
people are gonna start looking at you
people are gonna take you up people are
gonna watch that game back like okay
this is what he does i'm gonna be ready
for it and just like that we saw
greetings was ready for it you know he
went for the interesting combo enders uh
into some setups the first time it
worked next time i didn't try it again
didn't work you know like mob is he's
being counter played here too right now
so it's up to him to to sort of that's
the thing when you're in in position in
his position right like um when you're
at the top it's you know see you can't
look down and see everyone you know like
these guys they you are so highly
visible everyone's watching your game
everyone you play you don't get to see
everyone play don't see what they do
especially with a character like king
can be very scary but i like this choice
here mumpo's elected to go for the
infinite stage
yeah i've noticed that he likes the
infinite stage which is kind of unusual
for a lot last player he doesn't just
pick it against king i've noticed he's
done that in other games but this is
definitely the right choice especially
in the context of that previous match
king got a lot of wall damage
come visit arctic snowfall
we've got great weather
on the holiday
uh
what do you call it holiday bruscho's
type video
looking so good right now
about three
about four
two one
interesting choice there
very sensitive start from both players
well not the best we're punished there
dress it almost doesn't work out nice
break on the regular throw half the
round is gone
oh nice
can go for the fourth floor neutral two
slow starts up forward two nice punish
there from greetings
oh great low parry again on the down one
powerbomb wants to follow up here
just stays down the wire
four greetings four rounds straight over
the evo ears champion
looking very strong indeed press this
button's there though
he needs this this is a great start now
from mob he needs some momentum
running three last frames nice break on
the throw
is it again doesn't work out two
well down four two doesn't commit to the
second hit
oh crash dash was done in one plus two
very nice
he's a little bit worried about oaky i
think he's worried about you going for
something big and just getting
completely lightning screwed into this
into oblivion but i like it
punish that no that's not the patch no
duck from mob though could have launched
and potentially the round is he going to
regret that he could
race drive spent down board one
okay what patience no oh my days he's
got him
eat my heel
what a weird
double know ran brown
what is going on in our winter
semi-finals
is in serious trouble right now again
the crowd that's one plus two what's the
key
greetings takes it six rounds straight
over mob the eu east
champion that is
that is the biggest upset of the day i
have this
it really is it it really really is and
that sets up a
hell of a winners final that i wouldn't
have called
the winning yes the winners final is the
opposite of what we expected we were
expecting the ladder versus lmg mob
instead it is now her greetings going up
against bumblebee the underdogs on both
sides managed to take it and that
is surprising
to say the least i mean if i'm if i'm if
i'm mob right now it's like fine okay
you know i'm in the i'm in the loser's
backyard i've still got i'm still i'm
still alive that's the thing they're
both alive they're it's not like they
lost and they're completely out right
now they're still alive i mean just take
a look at some things we had happen in
this game right you know this round
could have been mobs but again the tech
catch there i think the only way out of
that is like roll forward or something
which is something that's just going to
betray your muscle memory you're not
ready to do and then
like they're set up
straight into the spring kick like
mob just have to be patient wait he
needs to do a ground [ __ ] sounds like
ford ford too maybe i don't know
um and yeah he was just very unfortunate
wasn't doing the right things and just
like that
greetings moves into the women's plan to
play against bumblebee
one of the things i like he did there
was obviously he didn't uh always take
his oaky he wanted to see what he would
do and looking into the future look at
this
we have so many more events waiting for
all of you this is a truly world online
tour and we have
africa tomorrow which you said you're
casting tomorrow are you commentating
yeah i'm looking forward to that south
africa next week middle east south asia
southeast asia philippines and east asia
oceana korea and then ending with japan
and then look at those regional finals
events as well i mean so many of these
regional finals will be almost
completely decided by the masters
there's so many points up for grabs at
the masters and all i would say is that
if you don't want it to be like that
let's get the dojos going let's get them
online
you know i kind of want it to be decided
by the masters events because i'm only
in uh where serial fighters is the
master and so let's stop
all dojo's in western europe at this
moment so i can just keep my spot that'd
be very nice um but yeah you see you
know the the regional plans will be
beginning in november starting off with
south africa going to middle east
america and so on and so forth um and
yeah they're going into until christmas
and past and they end in north america
in january of next year so it's see the
marksman started with north america and
then they go and they end with north
america as well so
really fun to see that and we see the
next games we have coming up for you
guys strobe versus vaughn and frisian
versus olegino these ones these are the
players i'm expecting i want i'd expect
all of them to have deep runs but only
two of them can so uh strong versus one
gonna be a an an interesting game to say
the least i wanna know who ron picks for
that match up um because vaughan known
for that i know sword lily play lily
early 10 we know he has a kilomits as
well and then frison versus oligino i
mean that's going to be most likely i
mean that could actually be nero versus
[ __ ] from depending who frizz in the
next two i haven't seen much that steve
recently has been he's been committing
to the dark side going for lee where i'm
not a fan of it but if you want to win
you gotta do what you got it takes to
win when you want to win in the
situations that you gotta win so
um yeah we'll be getting those games up
for you guys very shortly
now you play a bit of steve because
you're a high-rank player and it seems
like if you play horror and you have to
play a bit of steve don't know what
that's about nonetheless i think anna's
pretty good against steve
i think you say that i think it's an
interesting match up um i think the one
thing that can make the matchup really
annoying for steve is he can't launch
and the snake edge
so the snake edge
becomes very viable in that matchup
because it's a high crush so you're
going to beat stuff like black one the
jabs steve's most important tools and
then you get a full launch and if it
hits so that's something to think about
and then there's less risk obviously
with it being react we can low power on
reaction or whatever but um that's
something to keep in mind but in general
i think steve can control neutral very
well against anna you know he can just
keep her out back one down four two down
four two is very good the moment she
does dark in your face you can just do
down forward too and just nullify the
full crush mix option if you're ready to
do it so
you know i think i think it's
interesting but there are things that
anna has going for in the match up so
it'll be interesting who who both can
pick strong could go for lots uh vaughn
could do it for lily or kanemitsu so
let's see it's going to be
anna versus steve what is going all out
this is what i wanted wanted to see i
mean i yeah i think you're right i mean
i think the matchup changes dramatically
at different ranges and if anna gets
steve in the vortex it can be can be
tough but then anna has to take so many
risks
it's going to be interesting yeah i mean
one of anna's best neutral tools are
probably her qcf1 uh which is the the
high album that's the countdown launcher
that couldn't be a terror for steve
because i've played this match a few
times against um uh haroon actually when
he ruins anna and that could actually be
a terror to deal with
um so let's just see how strong is able
to play around that nice just straight
up starting
something
nice uh step now that's the thing and
it's full crouch makes you have to walk
it to the left side will left and you
beat it
go into the wall here very nicely for
one nice there it is the snake edge
can't launch it just gets a while 31-2
up forward three two okay strong that's
how you feel
oh but nice walking there to the back
this is classic stroke right now going
to the wall no just shy
doesn't get a full spot
okay punch nice
i mean stuff like that as well other
characters can launch steve cannot and
there it is vaughn gets on the board as
well we have a tight one already
one
big sweep there from barney's taking a
lot of risks right now
all right down back three two stomps on
the toes that one plus two bar needs to
get up that one plus two again
nice patience therefore but the sonic
bang from out of nowhere what is strong
being that we aren't
fight
he's seen that van's pressing a lot of
buttons i guess that must be it
all right down two one two finishes the
string nice gets the float on the
sprinkler we're going to the wall sonic
bang no messes it up
forward one this is looking like strokes
around right now well i need to do
something big if he wants to get back
into it interesting
can he carry to the next wall almost
oh threatening the full crash mix
just again the sonic bank from out of
nowhere that was clutch
what's he gonna do with it backing
himself into a rage drive spent no
movement there from stroke
oh gets the counter hit nice sidestep
there from van to get more damage on the
combo it's not going to be dead though
he gets to the back
four steam of the kittens oh this is
dead he's dead he's dead
what a choice oh
i have to vaughn could have won that i
think it was good from there just from
stroke to stay down but it bonded
sidestep three which is a ground hitting
mid um i've that might have killed i
don't know but would have put my
situation to get the kill there that get
out fall really changed around in the
moment struck up he just just sidewalked
put ana's back through and then raise
your hand and that was going to be it
then the worst part about that is like
the whole time you're blocking the
punches you just know you're dead
yeah
your face is sealed
yeah they both played so well both of
them were just getting their stuff in i
actually thought that
um the way van was using
anna at close range was quite clever he
wasn't getting pulled into any silly
fights he wanted to get into the offense
his way and not not try and get into a
war of fire with steve it was really
interesting and the way he was using the
wall as well like uh using stance to to
really employ some good mind games and
then peed him off the wall for more
damage and good oaky he was looking good
yeah i think one thing as well i think
maybe while we're seeing stroke use
sonic bang is because um one thing when
anna first came out that most people
sort of uh picked up whatever was her
punishment isn't fantastic
you know
when we got fantastic punishment it
improved over time but something like uh
sonic thanks only minus 12. and it
doesn't really get a great punish if it
hits and i think stroke is making some
reads on von's movement and timing so
it's his it's every time he's doing it
hits
so uh be interesting to see how if we
continue this upper bound just pays a
bit more patience and i do want to see
ron force the mix up a bit more you know
i want to see the full quest download to
use the wild center i want to see more
of that he needs to start forcing his
he's like strong is just dominating too
much you need to put the fear of the mix
up in his heart and try and get your own
star uh your own stuff going
he's doing it well at the wall but maybe
not so much in neutral and that's what
we need to see some changes on
fight
here we go now we're at the howard
estate
the party stage
what a read already starts off with the
launch going to the wall
nice patience again but get sidestepped
and will get hurt
it's interesting to see as well that uh
vaughn went for a random slope did not
pick stage so you know oh nice running
too they even if you wanted to power
that you couldn't you can't parry
running moves um i know players will
normally like to go to the forgotten
realm because she's so strong in that
game stage so many of her moves become
normal hit launchers with a full break
um so it's interesting to see they just
didn't pick a stage
there's that core circle forward one
that we talked about earlier barely seen
it at all in this game
i'm like three two one staying down
there
oh going on that one they have to be
very careful that situation but the
cyber will save stroke there punish the
watson one two the wild man cometh but
nice punish there run up into back two a
nice an extra flicker jab in there to
make sure he could peel off of the walls
struck as prepared
he really is and he's not he's not being
gonna crush him too much at all where
you know you're looking to crush steve
as much as possible but he's not giving
her the opportunity to do that
going to the war
this is technically a law match as well
oh yeah they're related aren't they yeah
oh but there's the snake edge and we
have to see more of that providers get
going even with the block not going to
be launched
no duck there from stroke down to one
finished string nice power crush there
from vaughan
just staying alive that's what you need
to do there it is the forecast down for
two you need to get those mix-ups going
var needs some momentum right now
not the best combo goes for the sweep
our question again big whiff not the
best punish from stroke but he'll take
it
down forward two very nice step from bar
not respecting strog anymore side step
three one more hit the one plus two
there's no great then we're going to a
final round second game
france decided to to bring it more
offense and he's working out for him do
you need to see more of those lows i
think um
no duck on the final hit of the string
okay nice guys launch here
one will not carry to the wall so nice
sexy spike great patience there oh
okay i need to talk about that situation
though that was very unfortunate for von
he did the cjm for those of you who
don't know anna's cat stance where she
puts her leg up has an auto low parry
where she gets to launch with the
hopkins you have to do anything
he did down back three it worked but he
did down by three two and for some
reason the second hit
just clipped and
i don't know yeah it didn't make sense
that should have stopped the first move
i mean what i'm guessing is just down
back through two which is too fast you
know the two was just too fast
that um even if the autoloader comes out
it's going to come in a trade and that's
probably that's one of those scenarios
that like you rarely will ever see in
this game in a situation that was an
auto loan parry like i guess danbot 32
is one of the only moves that can do
that so strog
moves forward uh and he'll play against
gallander so we'll be getting strong
versus gallander in a second before that
we're gonna have prison versus oligino
and this is all these games i can't
can't stress enough how much i'm here
for this i'm here for all of this it's
every single match could could be i mean
i would say every single match i could
conceive being the final apart from what
is actually in the winner's final right
now no disrespect meant to the players
at all but that's what i love about
tekken tournaments you see things you
just do not expect and you can you can
just you know guess as much as you like
what's going to happen but you'll be
proved wrong 90 of the time i mean if
you look through the bracket and the
players who's a witness and loses it
does look flipped players like galanda
and strog and mob you'd expect to be on
the winner's side and then you know
greetings and mobby obviously the
lesser-known players you expect them to
like more likely be on the losers side
but they have just been
they've uh been they've been playing out
of their skin especially bumblebee land
off you know i mean the actually both of
our winners side matches were six rounds
straight were they not yeah they were i
know that king win
that that that right that wasn't one
i get defeated you sometimes don't like
king back back in our history when we
used to play like
he can drive you mad i know people going
on about twitter about train grabs
recently but let's get it straight the
way he played king it wasn't like oh you
got a few train grabs you got lucky you
know you made a few 50 50 reads he
actually backed up offline significantly
and only went in when he felt it was the
right time it was a really fantastic
performance and a very very seasoned
king by the looks of it so i'm looking
forward to seeing more of that
i think the one thing as well that kind
of surprised me is that well i guess
didn't surprise me is that the fact that
we're seeing so much russian players
yeah and this top eight since they're
the top since uh season four sort of
started and uh the connections became
more playable in regions that's what
like the western european players don't
see a lot more of the russian players
and we started to see how strong these
guys were in the unique style one player
that surprised a lot of people who are
unfortunately we didn't get i don't
think end today was mickey a very very
strong brian player who during icfc was
actually playing in an internet cafe
um he was traveling to an internet cafe
to play his games in icfc and then i
remember one time he actually made grand
finals so it's like two in the morning
three in the morning over and watching
this guy's the internet cafe playing he
was absolutely insane like his movement
was crazy um one thing i really liked
about his and something i see other
watchmakers they struggled to as well is
when they're in your face they don't
dashboard they walk forward
to realign with you
so it's like you're trying to step
around it's not gonna work because
they're walking forward in your face
stopping you and then they realign and
instead of getting the character we
expected steve versus [ __ ] rum we're
getting leeroy versus negan and this
probably the first time i've ever seen
this matchup in my life
i was gonna say the same thing i've
never commentated this i i've never
played this i used to play a little bit
of leroy before we also a lot of players
stopped and uh yeah this is i've never
seen this i'm looking forward to it
and you notice frison he'll use the
stick
well it seemed in the last two games he
used that stick very very quickly he
wanted to make sure he got that out and
never had it unused let's see if he does
that again in the first round i mean
it's common to just not want to die with
your resources so just use it as early
as possible
especially this is a one-time use thing
not like ready to get every single round
you might as well make use of it um so
yeah so
libra versus negan is an interesting
might have to say at least a negan i
think is such an underrated character in
this game uh normally people really play
them at the top level you see a white
honey take the character down the nice
intro there with one one plus two
um but i don't think you don't really
see many people play the characters
interesting because you know people say
oh it's not fantastic he doesn't have a
homie move with negan he doesn't really
need one because stepping him is a
mix-up his dr his jabs will track one
way and it's down for one tracks the
other way which makes him a nightmare to
step if he's just playing a simple
poking game but as i speak uh frison
takes the first round very fast
very fast indeed
oh my god
four two two from out of nowhere we're
going to the wall as well this is a
great start here from prison the
neighbor has really been working out for
him today oh you need to get up or
lagino
i think we may see some more that i mean
what just took my breath away was the
fact that he baited a big whiff punish
and he just absolutely smacked him for
even going for it oh nice oh
combo there down back four great start
here from prison
very very quick play again
oh
there's the king he wanted the whiff
once they didn't work up a nice step
though in the background plus two off
axis does he know the combo yes he does
okay get out before there beats the
hermit stands that can't pursue the plus
frames
oh nice parry there orbital
back one to interrupt ryzen looking
really good right now can you do a no
round brown
okay the spring casing up down 3-2 and
just like that prison takes the first
round
three
rounds straight what a stop
what is going on today
this is crazy i like the way frison he
he didn't let him really get into any
rhythm of his okie at all he was he was
doing get get up kicks he was just
making sure that he wasn't stuck in a
vortex of having to deal with down back
to and the subsequent mix-ups it was a
really consummate performance i mean
that's got to say look i'm sure he's got
to go back to his [ __ ] man that was
that was insane he even parried the
shove like that can be quite jarring
when someone parries your shove i mean
the thing is is uh they sort of when
[ __ ] run was a huge problem people
sort of picked especially pakistan
people would pick leroy as a counterfeit
for the character the main reason being
if he goes for his charge up so you can
just know bring back to you parry a lot
of things he tries to go for the guard
break and also his punishment was pretty
good and [ __ ] rum so made him uh he
couldn't really play his game uh
fantastic the matchup is pretty much in
leroy's favor
um so maybe that's what he was thinking
going into this i'm going to try negan
instead it's not it's not the same but
negan account sorry lyra character can
still parry everything the weapon
doesn't really change anything so
the if interestingly go to the character
switch here i don't know what i do in
his situation
i think it's so difficult versus frison
if you
even if you win your first game he may
switch to steve which is well known to
be one of the best thieves in europe or
has been over recent years it's a it's a
real battle i'd say this is massively
uphill now for allegheny let's see what
he does
steve as well also a good pick against
[ __ ] run because that 142 controlled
the neutral space um
it'll be interesting to see how he plays
this
yes interesting now leroy versus [ __ ]
rum this is these are the characters
that terrorized
second seven throughout the years when
they first came out
made people uh
quit the game
my heart breaks to see these guys beat
the crap out of each other it really
does yeah
the thing is though no matter who wins
here we're all losers
nice nice dark prison but no punish is
aware i mean allegheny has been doing
that a lot the three four four ah that
high has been doing that last bit
pre-terror telegraph now no punishment
three four but guess the count and hit
nice runs up to this down back to the
shaolin punches
back no punish
oh run up into background between just
like that prison gonna take another
round is this four rounds straight it is
it is and i think and just to add to the
weight of
various things on laguna's shoulders
poland has some pretty good [ __ ] rams
tocus for example we've seen him before
very very strong fracking ram frison
would have seen all of this before we've
already seen it with some of his ducks
but he gets caught by that doesn't get
converted easy it wasn't a good ball
splat but then he just carries on he
plows right through him on the board for
allegheny i mean one thing i don't like
he's doing he's doing a lot of a lot of
three one down four that is launched
punishable in the stringing and you can
doubt the three one and you see more
people ducking that he shouldn't be able
to get away with that for three for free
oh but the other one orbital the trade
though works out for prison
number four jet kick
three four four three four no punish
there from prison minus thirteen back
two three no duck on the string
this stage not necessarily helping
frisson wasn't allowing him to move on
yeah
that's a combo that lyra can only get on
the big boys very nice here great start
three three
oh my god the big strap string twice in
a row prison one right away from moving
forward didn't i lose his bracket right
now
nice block nice punch oh great step
there from prison
three four no punish again minus
thirteen
oh big whiff on the jet kick no punish
goes for the cane instead being quite
unfortunate with that
one plus two nice punishment one four
but back nine one plus two is then is
the move of the day
one three four the okay and that's gonna
be the game oh that will be it the
hermit four four
breaks start there from frizz and he
moves forward in our lucid bracket
commiserations delegate but it just
looked like prison was i'm not the
difference between allegheny's earlier
match against hamid was you know he was
pending at someone who doesn't really
know how to deal with falconram like
everything's working on my strings but
you know playing against prison he knew
what to do and uh speaking of steve
players strog that flickered that extra
flicker jab there to pick up off the
wall was just super impressive the great
presence of mind and awareness to do
that there someone i'm expecting to go
very far on this bracket one got
unfortunate to get to that point uh the
cjm launch should have worked but i'm
actually through the second hit
uh but there we go that was great
awareness there from prison to know you
can actually get a combo on that on fire
come around normally just get a
guaranteed r43 plus four four um but
you've got a full combo there which is
something you only do honor certain
characters
prison just wouldn't let him get go as
well whenever frison i mean just in that
in that um replay we just saw there was
a period of about 10-15 seconds where um
pakam was trying everything to get get
prison but frison just wouldn't let it
happen and then when prison got in he
just he just steamrolled him it felt
like one of those games where if frison
could get fully in he was just he was
just gonna run run right over him and
great oaky great reads great wall game
and frison continues on
so
let's have a look at some of the merch
we've got available to you wonderful
people look at this
what are you going for there okay whis
yellow or black
i'd probably get both i feel like you
know just it's not it's hard to choose
so i'd get both and wear them at the
same time
i like it that's that's what i would do
well it's good because it is it's like
it's the fact that the bruce lee colors
but like they don't exist without each
other you know what i mean like if you
just have the black one just have a
black one just like the yellow one just
a yellow one so it's like i feel like
you need that you need to have both i i
know i never
production tell me i'm gonna look like a
bumblebee um and i'm prepared for that
i'm prepared i never got the game of
thrones reference very good point indeed
well can we have a look at the next one
what game the difference game of thrones
did i say game of thrones i meant game
of death good ass tekken uh
uh oh i mean i love this [ __ ] i went i
went for the black one i i just thought
the black one looked very clean i'm
looking forward to getting this king
shirt beautiful more versatile i can't
even see what movie is doing
well what do you think he's exactly
doing it in security
um
i thought he was doing
forward forward three
uh sorry battery just frame
he's finishing that
i i thought it was an enzyme and then
anakin said he's doing a shining wizard
so it seems like you see that too it
seems like no one really knows what he's
doing right now i'm working compliment
i'll talk to her yo what move is uh king
doing here you know i just just need to
know and make sure you guys also check
out all of the uh social media as well
for uh uh and i'm current i can you see
that the twitter there be any esports uh
the youtubers all being especially one
there's a tech and twitter twitch and
facebook make sure you follow all of
these we have so much action coming uh
for you guys in the future so you're
gonna make sure you don't wanna miss any
of it you want to miss the rest of our
tournament when we cut back from this
short break
no there isn't there isn't i lied to you
i'm sorry um there's no break guys
we're going to look at the bracket first
okay so when final pep greetings versus
bumblebee all russia battle not the
russia battle we expected on paper maybe
we thought strog versus mob i mean there
are lots of different combinations here
they're moving down the italian living
in bulgaria gurlander we all know him
playing against strog again that looks
like it could have been a final and then
mob versus frison i mean this is great
we've got some good representation
across eastern europe obviously we've
got that russian domination what do you
think kowis do you think we might have a
russian winner
i mean it's it's very likely um and that
mob versus frozen game is actually a run
back from evo online eu east those who
played
uh and the winners semi-final i believe
so those are going to be familiar with
each other i think that's part of the
reason frisian has been sticking to the
last because uh sorry to the leroy
because steve did not work out when
those two played last
i can't wait to see how it all works out
and we're going to go to a quick break
oh okay we're going to do a break so
this time i'm tricking you guys we'll be
back soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
so
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
play as goku and experience the story of
dragon ball z in the action rpg dragon
ball z kakarot plus a new power awaken
set for nintendo switch
[Music]
in this game the magnificent original
story you will play will include the
most famous scenes and even completely
new ones never before seen in previous
games
this is the real goku experience from
spectacular battles free flight and
sharing meals with many dishes to
developing relationships with many many
characters
in addition exclusive nintendo switch
features add much more to your dragon
ball adventure
[Music]
let's explore dragon ball z in all its
glory with its numerous features and
gorgeous graphics
[Music]
in the power level system every action
you take with goku leads to his growth
[Music]
increases power level through all
actions including fighting meeting
people and eating
[Music]
level up by defeating enemies and
gaining experience
[Music]
the more powerful enemies you defeat the
more experience you will gain growing
even stronger with every battle
you can also gain experience by fishing
hunting animals and fighting dinosaurs
after cook up and eat all the
ingredients you gather from around the
dragon ball world with every meal your
strength and power will increase and you
can even get temporary buff effects
[Music]
the more you eat the stronger you become
so don't forget about cooking
in particular the courses prepared by
goku's wife chichi are excellent and
will have an even better effect
[Music]
in training grounds you will grow goku's
power by fighting against z warriors
powerful enemies from the past and even
yourself
[Music]
after defeating each opponent you will
unlock a new special attack
[Music]
z orbs are essential items that can be
collected on the field or obtained by
defeating enemies by using these z orbs
and your super attack skill tree you can
enhance the special attack you have
learned through training or learn
know-how passive skills that will always
remain effective
[Music]
in order to advance your adventure
connection with your friends is
essential
by completing the main story and
substories you can earn soul envelopes
which deliver a variety of effects by
placing them on the community board
[Music]
certain combinations of characters can
result in a bonus so it is important to
consider character compatibility and
place them appropriately
i don't know about that
where's your same pride go on say you're
going to surpass me
like you just accept him saying that
only on nintendo switch bonus content is
included from a new power awakens parts
one and two where you can earn a brand
new power through training and also
fight beerus and golden frieza
[Music]
additionally the option to select the
difficulty level of the game from easy
normal or hard is also included
there are even subquests where
characters will become playable
[Music]
a story for all dragon ball fans
the real goku experience with incredible
depth and beautiful graphics pre-order
today to secure even more bonus content
only available when you pre-order and
only at participating retailers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and welcome back you lovely people to
the tekken online challenge event for
eastern europe i'm abominable and i'm
with the legendary k-west how's it going
dude you just returned i told you
legendary just return that back to me
just did it just did it back to you all
right
thank you appreciate that um but yeah
here we are back toc eu east
uh big thanks to everyone competing also
a big thank you to astro the official
mix up and headset the second online
challenge for 2021 always supporting
second you really do love to see it
don't you abominable i love it i'm
wearing them and i'm they're they're
comfy as heck and uh they're seeing me
through very well with this tournament
first there were 77 from all over
eastern europe and now there are six and
what a six we've got for you the these
guys are any one of them could take it
and i've been so excited with the
matches we've seen we've seen some
unexpected blowouts we've seen some
incredibly close games we've seen some
characters you don't always see so yeah
i'm
we're looking very very good today and
look at that in the winners final
greetings versus bumblebee and then the
losers quarter final gurlander the
italian playing at bulgaria versus
strzok one of the favorites mob again
one of the favorites playing against one
of the top pro polish players prison it
couldn't be set up better
honestly it does look like the losers
and the winners side is swapped you know
it looks like there was a bit uh
a bit of some some some change changing
going on there and they just switched
swapped the other side or in the upside
down um but yeah you know bumblebee and
her greasing's played so well to get to
this point and put those guys into the
losers bracket so it's gonna be
interesting one thing that really
excites me though is it does look like
strogan mob on a collision course and
i'd love to see those two play
but i feel like the i don't know i don't
even call any game in those losers
brackets either win an upset mob versus
frison those two going either way two
top european players frisian who's uh
proving himself over years of tech and
more tour experience playing very well
in poland and when he travels out to
other events as well always doing
amazing and mob the evil online east
champion someone who you know has really
come out of nowhere for some people who
haven't been paying attention and
really made a name for yourself and then
galana versus strog i mean
i i've spoken a lot about struggling
into this day mainly because i don't i
haven't felt like i've needed to speak
about someone like garlander like his
his his his name speaks for himself he
needs no introduction the 20 2018 lcq
champion that is i feel like the l the
tekken award to lcq is probably the
hardest tournament on the planet second
you know everyone who hasn't made into
the top 19 is looking to compete and you
know it is a bloodbath ah you know no
one is safe in those ornaments so it's
when that was a big statement there so
everyone knows about glenda but strobe
versus galander that's gonna be an
amazing game that one can definitely go
either way but before we get that we are
getting mob versus prison it is the lars
versus the leroy so prison coming to
that leroy here today he is really on
the dark side right now
come to forgotten realm where the
structural integrity is top class
what it takes is one little tap and that
ball goes in available for voiceovers
a nice black force that's a great option
there from mob gonna be a lot of options
that they go for that back four is gonna
be huge whenever you see frisian going
to hermit stunt we're going to see mob
do that a lot because the classic
slobacki that lyra plays will do there
or doesn't work on these
i can see bob he wants to get in and
force a full crouch game he just like
doing it but frison was ready for it
yeah that was the great we've punished
there from prison but not a good combo
at all he might be able to kill this new
race drive 142 into the follow-up nice
block but that's not it nice block right
back
one more hit does it could have done
more than
oh my goodness
i thought that i i thought for sure that
i was gonna hit i thought for sure
great
there from mob breaks the floor
immediately
he just showed good awareness just to
carry on that nonetheless and not get
phased by it all back full case
cool pressing buttons no punish there on
whilst anyone is not looking good right
now doesn't duck the second half down
three two you have to duck it if you
want to get the full launch
budget hell sweep hits him
challenge
mob does not care right now great start
here for mob yeah i think unfortunately
for frison though he should have had
that first uh first round
is it gonna be ten thousand nine hundred
and thirty nine
the lmg mob i know that's the question
you're all asking
too many wins
that's a lot of second there's no rights
broken by frieza needed that high
sidestep punish
and that one plus two one the best move
best moves in the game at the back four
count it again things looking so good
right now for mob the backwards workout
but again not a good combo by frison he
might be able to kill if he did that
correctly nice patience by mob down two
oh my goodness prison isn't done yet but
he needs to get his combos sorted out
not at all mob getting so much juice out
of that four as well he does five more
damage this season and he's really using
it well
the hermit parry is going to go for a
mix-up here
doesn't work out nice patience there for
mobber again just to dig that dick jab
string twice and frozen stays the line
alive fighting around first game
doubtful one backing up slowing it down
a little bit now oh
from out of nowhere this was looking
like it was gonna be mob's game but
maybe not right now
mom does duck up in your grill quite a
lot so if you're gonna make the reef
it's going to pay off
it's going for a self nice patience
there from prison a swiping swipe
down one he went for the cane didn't
work out and just like that mob will
take the first game and that was what
about the closest games i've had this
topic let's be honest
yeah i mean i'm confused wasn't prison
just winning that round like
didn't he just spend niddy all that
around winning and then then mob just
spent five seconds taking all that lead
away that was crazy
you know um but yeah one thing i like
about um back four technically didn't
get buffed when you think about it this
season because like you said it gives
the extra five that was 85 damage but
season four they actually added extra
five health to the game so by the
technically it's not even a buff it just
does what it should have done it's just
more
inflation damage inflation i like it
usually just inflation right there um
but yeah great start there for mob but
frison he's looking in this this is
definitely a lot closer than when they
played an evil online uh frison could
have taken that game the first run you
have to say should have been his but he
just messed up i want to see prison
needs to do better combos you can't keep
do it you can't leave so much damage on
the table especially against someone
like mob is always ready to come back at
you so you need to end this game as fast
as possible
i agree i agree i think one of the
things mob does from watching the way he
plays is that he's looking to get up in
your grill and do
full crouch mix-ups and really make you
make some reads and he doesn't just sit
there in full crouch waiting for you to
duck like you know maybe a lead player
might do he he's very quick and he makes
you make lots of micro decisions all the
time so be interesting to see how frison
reacts to that he's chosen arena i mean
for me it's just like an equalizing
stage i mean i don't think this is
necessarily is going to change things
significantly for him other than take
away some of the bs
i mean with the walls and play is uh
anyone's game here but mob takes the
first hit
very nice start nice pace again using
that back four to beat sabaccy he
chooses to go for it nice punish
prison just swinging right now he needs
to get something started
yeah lots of whiffs
and again it's very hard to punish that
though great counter hit there by more
great start as well goes for the wall
bounce just shy oh no that's it
yeah
great patience there from mob and it's
just all the time with the audience to
sit there in there it was
rare you see someone so effectively
whiff punisher kane by the cane by rat
from range as well very good
going to the whoa whoa
who's that corvo that oh oh oh my gosh
goodness mob oh you do not see this
every single day and just like that one
more one but this is the thing prison
made the two-round comeback before can
he do it again
he's gonna have to do it
the hard way this is looking tough
okay this is becky or the door
nice side step
could have got more maybe
okay down three two not done yet punish
that yeah that's -14 perfect punish
there for mob and he is going to take
the game
over frison too oh and the stop you see
the stomach just standing there
right you see that his shoulders back
looking good good posture and everything
you like to see that um one word for it
okay
that was that was
dominant
bob look very strong
very strong i mean frizz in that first
game it could have gone either way but
that was just i was just mob in his
element ready to go and he takes out
prison uh when you look at the record
one favors to go through but
again just a
a phenomenal player absolutely
phenomenal player and he moves on to the
loser's semi-final to play the winner of
girlander and straw again oh my goodness
this is
oh
that game
that game is looking really exciting for
me you know i think also matchup wise as
well
because uh if strong goes for the steve
here traditionally one of steve's worst
matchups uh throughout second has been
katarina catherine's been very good
against the character that sorry against
steve you know her four counts down four
three goes under like his his back one
and he's down for two and the four
counts down for four actually i have to
say so when they nerfed steve the big
nerf they did to him
uh the downfall two not being homing
they actually buffed down four two as
well they buffed its lower hit box and
that's actually helped him in matchups
against characters like katarina because
that forecast down four three and at the
down four three plus four that's not
going to go under anymore that gives
steve the neutral control that he
normally has um and it'll be interesting
to see if that comes out in this matchup
so we could see him stick to the seafood
and galander go for the cat
it's a noticeable change to the hip the
hitbox i i i can even see it and i'm old
i've noticed that um
i get the feeling that garland is going
to play out of his skin here because he
won't want that last game to be in
people's memory whether he goes out here
or not like he he's he's definitely
going to play out of his skin he's
familiar with steve if strob goes to
steve i mean i think it could be a very
very close game i'm interested what mob
is thinking right now and i i don't
speak russian funny enough but i was
watching yeah i know
yeah
i was watching um mob's uh stream and i
could tell that he must be friends with
strog or he knows him very well yeah
because he it didn't sound like a
tournament game he was chuckling to
himself he was four rounds down and he
sounded super relaxed and he was just
like laughing it off i get the feeling
that they are probably friends but at
the same time does that mean you want
your friend to win because um
as you say strog usually beats mob um
those two from what i've known uh from
what i've heard as well those two are
like at the top of the russian scene at
the minute they play they played a lot
offline and offline is where strong
normally takes it you know they've had
quite a few games but uh mob has also
had some huge wins offline himself uh in
the russian scene so those who have gone
back and forth and it's like yeah it's
like when i feel like it's one of the
best feelings there's a top player
having like one of your also good
friends is also another top player you
guys have great tournament matches
together
um
so that yes yes it's it's fun that like
those two are our friends from more from
what i've heard so the interesting they
play again but you know stroke has to go
through galander first and that is yeah
there's no easy feat you know obviously
everyone knows he is italian but he's
currently living in bulgaria right now
so that's why he's competing in the uh
eastern european
uh online challenge so let's see the
characters that's going to be the start
of it yep no surprises katarina versus
steve's staff
let's see how it plays out on arena
i wonder if we're gonna see strog back
up like he did in the previous games
where we kind of lose 30 seconds to
movement alone
which is still quite kind of nice to see
or wherever he goes in a bit harder be
interesting to see what the game plan is
here
oh okay i mentioned it earlier it was a
lie the downfall too got beaten by the
by the low i lied i'm sorry
i thought it was just a bit too slow but
maybe you're right
i want to the plus frames
nice option select there from galander
just goes to the dick jab and one two
again he's trying to get the plus frames
going
good defense some strong
eats the odd hit but he's out of the
wall
now he's in rage on yeah nice usually
three three three gallander takes the
first round here right now
oh single hotkey doesn't commit that
would have been a nice launch there
yeah
that will crash down four three it's
really gonna work out for galander even
if steve blocks it he cannot launch
gets the flow but not ready for the
combo
[Applause]
downpour three plus four there
opening those lows going into the jabs
oh okay
i don't know what the truth is anymore
not gonna have a nice magic four and get
a connotion it's very hard to do that
off a single uh magic four there and is
that gonna be a whiff punish it is i
think
that was actually his throw break there
i don't think he he meant to do that
ranger i think he meant to do a thorough
break that's very classified characters
one plus two throw breaks
oh the albatross spin twice nice
interrupt their great low parry there
from
that is something i'd like to see change
that rage arts and rage drives initiated
by what would be a throw break it's
really challenging at times
lars has that same problem of course one
plus two oh that is the hard pick up
there off of flicker back two stroke is
definitely ready today
all massaging
down back three two down back two to
follow up look at this start here quite
strong
new harrier love colander's not that far
off from taking it back though yeah but
nice
is it wasn't just a thing early he just
has a read and it could uh all the time
it wasn't just for and
it's gonna go to the wall yeah neither
four four three combo very nice into the
stomp
i'm back three two nice oh have some
movement there as well so that that was
useful getting away great location like
a lander can't carry off of the wall
though
nice duck could have got more oh look at
that bad
okay rocket punch
yeah couldn't uh just got too far but
again run up into back two i don't know
what he's looking for not going to be
the round though qcf two the plus frames
nice block and oh my goodness garlander
puts everything on that low
final round let's go girl under versus
strong girl under doing far better than
he did in the last game playing out of
his skin
oh
the hot kick we're going to the wall as
well going for the max combos
perfect range for a max juggle
yeah just messes up at the end though
i'm back three two again and then he
gets the pickup this time that is not
easy to do
oh doesn't double second at 4 42.
but no not in the back but no punished
by gallander the punished by strong
running two plus frames rocket punch
like that
oh what's he gonna do down for two
the lander in rage they're quite
cautious right now one lord ends it for
either of them in the magic four by the
land he's gonna take the first game
that was a start
that was that was crazy good i mean it
was interesting what's what's trying to
look into shrugs mind is what he was
doing uh when katarina had that rage in
the final round he was just trying to
lock her down and stop her from pressing
buttons more at the wall but then when
he backed off did he go too passive
maybe it seemed like he just slowed down
a bit too much
i feel like what is starting to cost him
as well is those those
random sonic fangs it worked before
against one so i was sitting there like
okay this is it but now it's like
yeah you've got a coyote especially
against karina we saw carrying his punch
for it two two super good chunky plus
frames like it's it's not something you
want to mess with i feel like you need
to go back to using it on just to wear
punish the way it's supposed to be used
because that was not
that was not uh fantastic to say the
least uh man it's kind of what cost in
the game at the end of the day so you've
got to be a lot more careful there so
let's see um how he adapts that stroke
definitely isn't out right now but we
were seeing here why katherine was is
seen as such a good match against steve
the magic force the lows going on the
downfall too i don't know if the first
time it happened it looked like it went
under but then he caught the second time
so i just don't know
um but he switched to the lars
interesting very interesting indeed this
is the character strog initially made
his name with
over europe defeating all of the top
players i've known with the lars
let's see how it works here right now um
i
the thing is
i don't know if i agree with the switch
because you saw it was a final final
round final hit situation and he lost to
a magic four
you know that wasn't that wasn't like he
lost because of the character but lars
you're gonna have an easier time in this
matchup you're gonna have to play your
neutral a bit more you're gonna be able
to go under certain things so you know
it's it's not a bad decision
but maybe you could eat that with steve
let's find out great logo i agree with
you i agree with you like he also went
up forward four four a couple of times
right in the middle of the stage and a
lot a chunk of damage it wasn't like he
was ground down repeatedly over time
there were just some key moments
but still he's gonna last great art
class there
gonna put gallander in a rage 1.4 great
block for the wall but the wall he still
could no he doesn't get oh no oh no
so on both sides very unfortunate uh the
race drive connected but didn't get the
sort of throw follow-up animation uh
because of the side wall and then i
think stroke just panicked because you
know i saw he expected galan to do
something in that situation the drop
expected a follow-up went for the rage
shot um just panicked
look at that
absolute chunks flying air alex anderson
we'll punish that could have had a lot
more there well the harrier sweep that's
something punish that
nice again end with the art blast kevin
will mess him up though i don't know if
this is
scouted it he saw the last time galan
did that did the exact same fallout
finish that low committed and that was a
reset colander could have taken there
and the wall bounce do it again very
nice
it's gonna go low i knew it
down back we just have to in that
situation round four
fight
strong in the driving seat now
can only be using last for the rest of
this these next two games if it goes
that far i don't think he'll mind that
because last is doing a good job right
now with punishment this is the thing
you can do with lars you can't do a
steve you can with punishment launches
you'll see it and do the art blast there
it is again that's something that steve
doesn't have the same luxury forward
stuff like his back too it's just not as
not as versatile
[Music]
and there we go
that is going to be it that is a very
dominant showing there from the last um
and just showing you know the characters
bearing the match up and one thing we're
seeing is just one thing strong is very
good at is with punishment uh but when
you play a character like last instead
of steve you can launch with your with
punishment steve's back to
his options for launching aren't the
same can really be used in the same way
but uh strong is really making use of of
that last for the wave punishment
confident with punishment as well i mean
when you're playing in katarina and you
see in up forward four when it whiffs
there's a part of you
in your head that's thinking they're
gonna continue it and i'm gonna eat the
second hit but no he didn't even think
about it he just went for his art blast
straight away and took the damage yeah
and he played super strong his wall his
wall offense was very very strong um
it's looking tough for girlander now i
mean i wonder if glenda's gonna switch
he's you said he's been playing gunnery
of late yeah when gary first came out uh
galada was dumping a bunch of time into
the character so he played away back in
time too as well so
um he could go there
but i just i don't know it's not
necessary but i i'm not one to speak on
character switches because you know i
said he shouldn't switch he switched
look at what he did there so you know
like i said last is an easier time in
the match or better time with punishment
so let's see if that continues uh
galando maybe just a stage pick if i'm
glad i want maybe a smaller stage i
think because katarina really has found
those walls in play and a bigger stage
only benefits
switched dude let me finish my thought
though a bigger stage only benefits lars
because last is going to will carry
forever um regardless of the stage is
small or big um
so yeah but he's gone for again
he can carry you into tekken 8. but i've
noticed that
[Laughter]
can carry you into the west africa uh
qualifier tournament tomorrow now i've
noticed that there were a lot of lows
then i wonder if gallander is going to
make some reads and start ducking more
four four three four down back four
they're all being used quite a lot
blast again just getting struck so much
miles we're gonna get a sidewall here
nice ghost low gets the count hit
launcher catches galander's aggression
working against him but nice the back
ones through the head bar
punish that over tour
and down for three such a strong load
that gary has access to only minus two
but still the power crush guaranteed
very nice thereby actually that shoulder
wasn't guaranteed i don't think i think
the stomp is guaranteed but your back
look at the movement here by strong and
that's the thing i mentioned earlier
that russian style is so good with the
timing that's why characters like steve
and lars do they they really have fun
with that character over there nice
stuck there and i like the option it's
very hard to punish
the back ones are working now look at
this start here by stroke the running
three three it's looking like strong and
lmg mobile on a collision course towards
each other right now all he needs is one
more round and it's looking likely
let's see what glenn has to say about
that he hasn't really been able to get
anything in yet and he needs to nice
head but not gonna come with more
oh if he peeled off the wall that could
have been it
the ladder he's beginning and
using
freeze
oh he went for another as well but that
is it yeah that takes him out for i i
feel like he should have stuck to the
cat i could say that in hindsight
because it didn't work out it just
looked like gary wasn't ready but
strog is just on point right now i mean
i i feel like at one thing people are
yes strict says strokes like green rank
right now but strong was actually the
third person to get second god omega in
europe i believe
he was the third or fourth person to do
it in europe um but then he uses a
different account and save our
corruption or whatever so that's why he
is that right people um even though rank
is it rank means nothing i just need
people to understand this guy was one of
the first to do it on the on the on the
bigger stage that we see it all came
down to that in the first game you know
just messing up his timing there i
didn't think he had to switch there but
you know the lars just came in really
strong right now this is the the
character he made his name without the
start
um i do think at the end i think the
last pick was good i thought the the
gamer you pick wasn't it i thought the
language was not the cat that almost got
it done but either way we have the game
that i wanted to see
uh
used a lot of pressure he he knew how to
play against gunnery as well you know
the the repeated running threes which
were starting to go into troll territory
but to be fair it it's hard with gandhi
if you're getting locked down with
pressure and movement it can make your
game plan very very hard to
put out there
yeah but also we have more events coming
you know this isn't the last one i mean
tomorrow is going to be the worst africa
than in two weeks south africa middle
east south asia south it's a truly
global
online challenge guys i make sure you
guys do not miss out um
and then obviously you see
uh the the regional finals will be
um starting in november going all the
way into a january ending with north
america so make sure you guys don't miss
any of the action i mean this like you
said earlier uh bumble a lot of the
people that are performing well here
today are making a claim for themselves
to appear in those regional finals and
could actually be what decides it
300 points for the taking which
completely blows the current points for
this region alone out of the water if
you get first second or third you're
going to be first second or third
in the rankings right now
and i like that i like that if you're
gonna if you get first second or third
you're gonna be first second or third i
like that
it's some it's quick math it's easy it's
straightforward
and winners find out look at that heck
greetings versus bumblebee losers
semifinal strog vs his friend looks
reversed
it looks like strong and energy more
should be the winners final and then
greetings and probably should we lose
the semi-final that's how that's the way
it should be but that's one thing i've
really liked about sort of the online
era of technologies people have come out
of the woodwork and made the upsets you
know it's about this guy to him but then
they win and
it's just it's always it's been all all
sorts of nonsense but yeah we'll be
getting our winners final it's our first
first three of the day huh greetings
versus bumblebee
please play king i love commentating
king i just love watching king players
they're the most entertaining aren't
they wait
it's an all russian top four
it is true
very true russia have won
i mean i have to say i've said it before
these guys they're they're unique style
attack and it's kind of like um
when pakistan first came onto the map
their tekken was was noted immediately
very with punishment reactionary heavy
uh great defense with the russians what
we noticed immediately was uh
their their patience their timing their
movement and spacing you know and it's
it's consistent throughout them uh
throughout most of them i think you see
it the best you see the best in stroke
in my opinion strogan mickey they're the
brand player the way you see the best
the best and you know they're just
ability to move around you um and one
thing i just i love when they do is then
they walk in your face to realign
instead of just like dashing or doing
they just do a walk in your face it's
easy you need to walk someone's face in
and do whatever like yeah you you're
susceptible people aren't going to be
hitting especially you guys like brian
or steve in your face you're scared
to sort of like push a button because
their counter hits are always looming
into those characters let me introduce
you to see how these games go but yeah
you know greetings and uh bumblebee
played amazingly to get to this point i
think they both won their games 6-0 so
they're both in great form right now
they're both looking really strong and
they took out two of the top players who
are expected to go very far this one and
put them both into losers brackets so
let's see
how this works and these two collide
i mean either of them are guaranteed at
least 150 points which is 75 more than
what the number one player has right now
in the region so they're they're gonna
they should be confident they should
know that whatever happens they're
looking pretty good and now now is just
the time to express themselves i'm
really looking forward to see what they
have
yeah they'll definitely putting
themselves into that um
into the top eight bracket just off of
this a lot of the players in this top
eight will be doing that so be
interesting to see how that goes and
yeah no surprises going to be the
kinimitsu versus the king
now is kuna mitsu gonna try and crush
the hell out of king or are we going to
see a more reserved affair
let's find out
i've really really enjoyed watching this
king uh play it's just so many good
fundamental king
skills and abilities that have been
worked on for some time by the looks of
it and this kuni mitsu is looking
incredibly strong as well
that's patience starting off with this
shenanigans
it's gonna be interesting to see what
what bumby really did well against
garland we'll just exploit his matchup
and familiarity and get there going to
be interested see if greetings uh knows
more is able to play around that a lot
and i like that they didn't have to
obviously look there um but then she'll
do that with two into teleport so you
have to watch out for that there is
wait for throw again
two throw
set two
oh no very nice
sometimes it's not punishable at the
perfect range it can be minus nine i
believe usually
in the
doesn't finish it again but you could
eat a massive hit for doing that but
bumblebee is playing more reserved rage
driving just the two options look very
nice
[Music]
punish that
go into the wall keeps his tailspin as
well four four one yeah
no no pushes away
actually doesn't finish it again
a little bit predictable here going for
the giant swing with his back to the
ball needs to switch it up finishes it
but doesn't and then he gets the giant
swing anyway yeah this is going to put
bumpy in rage and it's going to be a
very scary situation more mix does it
oh interesting choice
one throw broken
oh but the drop kick very nice there by
greetings one one in rounds that's the
thing king does have back turn moves and
can use them they're quite some of them
quite evasive up ford four
against getting deja vu here four
forward one
instant shiny wizard straight after
uh plus one plus two you can get okay
off this
tech roll nice
dude i'm no punished on it
wow
one rip there
i feel like greetings is just scared to
let it go and there it is the teleport
there's gonna be big damage will go into
the wall as
what's the well here
set three a yeah and just like that bomb
be looking super strong here
trying to get him to duck not working
again needs to mix it up more
finishes here angle slam
punish not the best punishment here from
greetings can get a lot more yeah i
could get back one two
three again and this is gonna go to the
no drops the combo a one plus two
they're not broken does he know the okay
kunai
no he backroad there could have had a
free kunai yeah
four two one is it this time but if it
doesn't duck it this is not looking good
for greetings
for two one again he's looking a bit
desperate right now blocks the manji
kick sir
punish that no punish oh and just like
that bumby will take the first game and
yeah i'm i'm seeing a lot of match up in
front of melody again here for for
greetings you know one two two no punish
he's not ducking correctly
um
i feel like people are just they're not
ready for kuni mitsui today everyone
everyone focused on laws everyone's
looking at mob okay we have to learn
lars in the background bumblebee was
just like practicing his killing it soon
and no no one saw that coming so you
know greetings gonna need to switch up
here if he wants to uh take this because
cooney is kind of running over him right
now
yeah i agree there are a lot of jab
punishes where there could be more than
that that one too for example and the
thing about the back one two punish as
you saw in one of the previous games um
is that you actually get
pretty much a guaranteed mix up there
after you i mean you're going for a 4-3
you're going for a throw you can use
those frames to actually get some good
movement in and get around them there's
all sorts of things you can do but if
you're not getting that bad one too
there's so many so much extra damage
that you're missing out on just doing
jabs isn't really enough there needs to
take take that damage where he can i'd
say the other thing is there was a lack
of creativity which i think if you're
playing at this level with king you've
really got to have you can't just be
doing those canned mix-ups into into a
mid or versus a throw you've got to
switch your timing up you've got to do
more than just doing the giant swing
with you back to the wall um and i think
he's even got to switch his timing and
creativity up here we'll just completely
switch
yeah i mean getting predictable king can
always be a pain but we are going to
forgotten from the true party stage
this is this is where king can really
let loose
and have some funky things happen so if
uh
if greetings wants to win this he needs
to make his claim here right
now he does indeed interesting choice
not all king players like to pick this
stage yes they get ridiculous damage but
it does also sometimes make them a bit
predictable
so we'll see how this plays out
i mean i just wanted
some crazy some crazy king shenanigans
right now let's just let's just get let
that happen right what's danny 2-2
nice punish it better no launch on this
set three there one third broken though
oh my gosh they're both doing their
their unique movement
he's looking to get in and do a throw i
can feel it i can feel it in my bones
ah
duck into an end to full crotch four two
nice
it's really going down oh my goodness
oh but no i can't get a combo as well uh
nice stuff
needless to use the floor though i think
a king purist would say don't bust
through that floor if you don't need to
but
good enough gets the round
forward one
four three
nice magic four options select
very nice went for the ground break
throw didn't get it very nice awareness
okay nice punishment this time back one
two in the while standing three it's
coming live now
set three again that is zero on hit
eating all the mix-ups right now
this hurts
break it
i think he could go for a jump over trap
here he's not going to do it
frankenstein doesn't work out rage
available and there it is for bumblebee
on the board here and all the flaws are
gone
yeah i don't think they've been used
optimally it'd be tough here but let's
see what happens straight out bumblebee
gets gets the launch and we'll get the
wall very tough here for greetings
very nice setup as well looks like could
even have got more whilst i need to
doesn't take the frames and eats the
launch that is so unfortunate and it
just looked like he lost confidence in
himself to go in and get the mix-up
round
i'll be just looking so good right now
could make this a quick when the
greetings doesn't wake up
not stuck again
nice punishment now for one two that is
-10 but there is the last hit of the
string you have to worry about
nice with punish
4-3
oh no wait for the right finish but
that's way too much gone
nice patience there on the wall standing
game
again doesn't finish it
punish things are looking good greetings
can steal this round in the cartwheel
okay
up three such a good end of round option
now two rounds a piece it's just gonna
go to a final game
set two
oh this is great awareness but it
doesn't finish it
tombstone that's it need to see more of
that less giant swing could have got a
ground throw
well not the best punish then what we
need to do is minus 14 can get whilst
any one one
one throw broken
again same situation
even with it
king can get crazy here no doesn't do
any of
the locks
oh nice spinny step
bumble bee can he steal this one plus
two so nice break there by greetings set
two into the hop and he does work out
great punish
downfall one just trying to keep it safe
great no parry by uh bumblebee though
but the wall's not gonna help him the
mangy kicks down forward one and the
alley kicks to end here we all tied up
one two one
felt it coming the alley kick is it's
actually not a bad option with your back
towards the wall like that because if
they launch you for it um you're
probably still alive so it's not not a
bad situation at all yeah
this is set up very nicely i feel like
uh king got away by the skin of his
teeth a little bit there at times there
were a few situations where it could
have easily gone the other way i think
bumblebee has reason to still feel
confident
yeah i agree i mean and that was that
was his stage pick as well and that was
still a very very close game you know
the forgotten realm still working out
very nice there for bumby you know he'll
be happy about that but we're going to
go for the infinite stage now as well
you nullify a lot of kings game and can
you miss me kuni mitsu's movement is
also really good for it so it'll be
interesting to see how that plays out
definitely definitely still i think head
greetings are still very much
in this there were situations where they
looked super super confident and they
did start to get more creativity in play
we're going for other throws other than
the giant swing and maybe an infinite
stage will actually make him think more
and not you know think okay i've got my
back to the wall i'll do a giant swing
i'll do back one two into four or three
sometimes that can loosen the player up
when it's infinite because they know
that there isn't a reason for them to
gravitate towards one certain option
exactly um we saw him do we saw him do a
lot it was very well with the walls in
place so be interested to see how
greetings plays without them
uh now like you saw him do some crazy
things in his earlier game you know
against mob with the walls in play but
now now they're most like i'm i was
speaking like we see the stage already i
feel like bumble's gonna throw like some
kind of herbalist and pick like an arena
or something
um if that is the case it's gonna be
insane uh because bumblebees you know
aggression i feel like well this is the
first time today we've seen someone
finally counter bumblebee's aggression
force him to play defense force him onto
the back foot and that's where he just
looks like he isn't comfortable so you
know it'll be interesting to
to see how that plays out uh moving
forward
yeah i just feel like there's some moves
that cooney has against king think it's
um while standing three the the the the
the somersault kick that looks like it
probably should be more punishable than
it is
i just think those moves actually
the amount of risk versus reward versus
a king player so much in kuni mitsu's
favor
and we saw him check it out quite a few
times sometimes it was blocked it wasn't
fully punished sometimes it was punished
but a bit late but that's that all
stacks up against the king player and in
the meantime you're getting a move where
it crushes heavily it isn't launch
punishable and you can kind of
speculatively throw it out here and
there um and i think that that can go in
kuni mitch's favor there's a lot of
crushing there a great back dash back
dash away from throws
um yeah it can be quite tough looking
yeah um and the way bumblebee's playing
as well is like really i feel like he
hasn't let the aggression funny go yet i
want to see more full crash down four
threes and sweeps like that just sort of
tested because once that low hits and it
hits from like range two very far away
it can be really scary um once that move
starts hanging you're already mixed up
you're already scared because you know
you see the range of you're like i
shouldn't normally have to duck from
this kind of range but could miss you
forces you to do that the flower will
forward forward too then it's the dash
forward you know then it's a back turn
mix up you know it really gets the party
star just one of those is really
important it's kind of i kind of like
it's like a kazuya's health street you
know the moment because here's how sweet
the party begins because you can't stay
down here's four forward four which is
uh safe now i can't hit launch before
you've tried match um when you get up
you take another mix it's going to be
the house again is it going to be one of
them it's going to be downpour one two
you know it's it or the down back too is
quite scary to deal with so that's
that's kind of how i like in uh
kinematics for crash down four three
just with a lot more range as well and
it truly high crushes so
bumblebee has switched to the ling
i don't know like this
i i par parmi likes it because of this
match up i know this is a terrible match
of the king yeah true um however
you only lost a close final round on
forgotten realm
i don't think there was a there was a
need for you to switch a character to be
honest but bomby was the character that
um
uh sorry ling who was the character that
bumblebee played before kirimitsu came
out so let's see if uh that um
with that that old-school knowledge that
he has helped him out here now yeah
fully fully agree
obviously ling is really really good
against king phoenix can do so much
against him there's so much of the stuff
that she does that just completely
evades and gets out of situations king
likes to enforce all that being said and
done the reason why i don't like it is
that you had proof you had visual
evidence that your opponent did not know
your character and could not handle your
offense that was enough taken to the
next stage get the stage pick but either
way look hindsight is a great thing
bumblebee is looking like
it was a good pick so far one round up
until you punish that one it's there
nice
it's the aop stance
already threatening with it there is
again
yeah it does this does force the kings
to go for forward one plus two try and
lock down that movement put it into
crouching and force some mix-ups but you
just have to be so careful
no punishment in two-two there
that too
anti-ling tech here
oh
one plus two will go into the wall as
well
nice very very nice smaller side or the
forward four again crushes the low
frankenstein and there we go greetings
is on the board
round three
one round a piece
would one catch his back turn doesn't
get anything off that
oh nice stuff there the moon so as well
great back bro catch shining wizard
instantly broken that was beautiful that
shiny wizard looked like it had to be a
giant swing
oh no didn't finish the combo one of the
clean walls that messes up great low
power on the rage drive though greetings
looking super good against the wing
right now
super awareness and very confident play
oh just the right wow this hammer but no
punish this is one thing we're seeing
for bumpy punishment is not on point at
all right now
now for one two
the cali roll there it is this is
exactly what bombings needs needs to get
started big combos big damage not the
best punish
or firecracker okay trying to set
something up the king wave dash
train grab what are we going for oh no
no no no no no no no he gets him
we're going round and round guys this is
gonna be great for him as well
what's the okay could jump over
no oh very very nice
again oh greetings oh gosh
oh the rdc oh boy oh boy oh boy
oh
god i didn't like it i didn't like it
i mean
yeah these things happen this is kevin
king's on the screen you should be ready
for it um unfortunately bumblebee wasn't
ready sometimes you're just mashing too
to break it and you just you just missed
you just missed the timing so hey whis
i'm talking to you on a private line
chat can't hear me right now ah stop
being negative about king i'm not how
about i'm not being negative about you
stop being negative about king i'm a
king player
you're just you're just biased towards
king that's what's happened to you
that's complete you see my neutrality as
negative you know what i mean so
yeah
getting into the matchup though great
great things i saw using up forward one
plus two at range can be dangerous can
get jabbed out of it but as it's great
if someone's moving around in phoenix
down forward one two it's ten frame
punishable i actually think that still
makes it a fantastic movie even if
you're getting punished here and there
you can delay it you can mix it up into
a throw if you spam it it it it doesn't
really matter too much you're going to
have to spam it a lot to die using that
move um and i i feel like he actually
used some really good anti-link straps
yeah he went straight back to kinder
mitsu do you
just realize yep that wasn't the play at
all that was something you should be
doing going to the kunimitsu i
understand the decision it was it was a
weird it was a weird i i i i think it
was just wasting switch the you only
lost a close game and forgotten rome
against king and you saw the greetings
are still struggling with some kind of
myths you think so i just yeah i don't
think um
i just don't think you could have
switched so early so let's see if one b
all right they sent me texturals knows
about the cooner
let's see one two one as well getting
the frame traps going
nice block and punish there from
bumblebee tries to throw his way out
though
all this pressure working out very well
from so far nice no break on the shining
wizard you can't stay down but he had to
break that throw there that could have
been the beginning of the end
oh he gets a job by accident and just
like that bumblebee stays alive
like this three things just needs one
more game here to move into grand finals
winning side nice option to select i
can't get a follow-up
i punished one two that's punished
definitely
nice dark wow shining wizard again
his instant shiny wizards are very
strong should we go for that more
they're not getting broken
yeah we're not seeing great thorough
breaks here from bumby
one two nice punish i think he had
counter hit there as well that could be
big punish that
downford one greetings looking super
strong right now
i get the theme bumblebee is breaking
one by default
and i think
if greetings abuses that then
it could work out pretty nasty it goes
about turn three it doesn't matter into
the launch again very nice that and gets
a clean wall splatter i didn't expect
that bomb we can't get away from the
moon so
oh the whole set one one two string hits
for some reason
not broken by greetings both therefore
breaks not the best right now and the
back roll catch greetings he didn't back
roll last time i'm surprised he went for
the kuni again the kunai again and so
was greetings
look he's catching bumblebee ducking now
the mids are the mids are coming online
you've got to use them
fourth one
oh this is nice to count here we're
going to the wall as well
i flopped
i think that was a giant swing there
punish that board four
set three nice he knows it's not plus on
hit
oh he's gonna be rolling again he's mad
man wait yes he needs to get back away
from the wall let me con doing just like
that bumby ties it all up at two two one
going to a final game
we are going to follow game and i just
can't i like that word that for
bumblebee but that side roll whilst king
had rage like in that situation i was
thinking to myself do not do that you've
already eaten some of this before but it
worked out for him nonetheless and we
are going to that final game i i can't
call this i
was very very close was that anyone who
like saw that in slow motion where i saw
greetings back to the wall like bombay
start shuffling a bit has rage available
we just knew exactly what was going to
come out there
um yeah unfortunate therefore greetings
gets hit by the rage and we're going to
a final game um but it's not the worst
case scenario for greetings because
you're probably just gonna pick
forgotten realm again so we're gonna
have the pie stage for the final game
i'd i'd guess so i'd guess so and
actually i as a king player
playing around that cooney rage drive is
really difficult you can't step it like
other characters might be able to well
walk
walk around it i wouldn't trust in
king's movement that way he's a wide guy
and his movement sideways isn't too
great so you kind of have to wait out
and try and get yourself away from the
wall and not eat too much of a mix-up um
didn't work out for him then and we are
going to this final
game and as you say is it going to be
forgotten realm
it is yep
yes his stage pick for the final game is
going to be really important really
going to decide how this goes
this is a pretty stage
it is but it's a dangerous you know one
wrong step and you go through the floor
yeah king has two throws that will take
half a bar at least um if you get uh the
right oaky after or the right juggle
after oh but there's not me nice if i'm
gonna be smart he's just gonna take this
opportunity to just break the floor take
those floors away from king exactly what
he's doing here
heartbreaker if you're a king player one
gone nice option there as well and this
should be the
okay bumpy gets the perfect but he
probably should have broken another
floor there you know you have that
chance i thought just take them away
from king as much as you can
yeah if someone does the reset on you
and then also gets the second floor
again it's another heartbreaker gets the
throw this time oh is he gonna get it
badly oh
three i talked about this before just
one begins the party style oh this is
looking like it would be a triple
perfect this is going to be a god game
you just cursed it now it's not going to
happen it's not wow this is this could
be no one
realm it's not going to happen if the
bumblebee takes the second birthday just
gonna do there it is see nice
okay okay
i don't want to see it oh he screws it
up yeah messed up the powerbomb i don't
know what he's doing minus ten no
punishment john's doing great punished
uh great throw break there by bomby like
you said maybe he's just breaking one by
default because there's a shiny wizard
which he doesn't break
sidewall again
his defensive okay is the same pretty
much every time yeah
i want to nice we're punished
patience here
who doesn't finish it
oh nice
okay yeah that's gonna kill you that was
i i feel gonna break the floor as well
with those just gonna get the kill
greetings is on the board
ballsy move to go for you can screw that
up especially in that situation actually
concerning he messed up an easy power
bomb earlier so
oh i think we're going to get our final
round just do punish the hot knee
don't you curse it now choice i i wait
punish that
could have had more knives stuck in the
back one two and we're going to a final
final round to decide who goes into our
grand finals on winner's side is it
going to be greetings is going to be
bumblebee and look is getting too
desperate for the launches now not
working out no that's not very nice
and now he's punishing that while
stunning three well doesn't get this
very wanted probably going for the
tombstone yeah they probably messed up
tombstone there
shiny wizard messed up
oh oh punish that not the best
it's a punish not the punish
nice again the options that the hawk
knee this isn't going to be the round
enough but it's going to be big for
bumblebee gonna put damage but greetings
in rage
qcf2 big damage
one two
race drive gone down four two
and the dark and punished by bumblebee
and he moves forward into grand finals
winner side showing that that link pick
didn't hurt him too much he's still
alive here
and greetings goes down into the losers
final
he did the rage drive he got the duck
that he wanted from his opponent but he
did it down four two have he just gone a
bit bigger
could have gone for a one plus two one
he would have got a wall uh a wall
bounce could have done all sorts of
things that could have taken it to the
smallest frog's hair of health between
the two of them doesn't go for it but
what a good performance from uh king
player he was just so good throughout
the tournament and he really showed some
great entertainment
yeah i mean i just think
it's just it just came down to that
final round he just looked too sensitive
like we mentioned earlier bumby was all
aggression always ready to go and i feel
like he just let bumby get off on the
front foot at the start and that
normally spells uh destruction when you
when that happens against bomby
you know but greetings you know he
stayed alive in this game before but
here is just
ah you just look at the situation rage
available look at the health like
greetings
and this needs to go back away from the
wall did not work yeah
i mean it's a shame as well because i
would say from greetings perspective he
grew into the set he was actually
punishing moves better as we went along
through the games and if you're doing
that normally that aligns with a win so
unfortunate but what a close match we
have we've had some uh not very close
games and that final game looked like it
was going to be at one point potentially
a triple perfect so he did himself proud
and he picks up a ton of points 100
points that's more than what the number
one player has currently in in the
region yeah so he's looking very strong
that was our first final final round of
the day but next up is
this is the game now going into there i
was looking forward to this is a
potential grand finals but no this game
is actually a battle for the uh for
fourth place the loser here goes home in
fourth place it's gonna be strong versus
lmg mob now i've spoken about struggling
off at this point i'm gonna try my best
to not speak about strong coconuts
i'm hungry now
you just like struggling off
strong you've never had a stroganoff
i've never had a stroganoff your comment
you're commentating an easter egg
it sounds like a euphemism for something
um i want i want no part of it um
yeah we obviously last mirror we are
gonna see the last mirror between these
two okay
okay this is it
this is this is why people watch tekken
this is it
i grip my teeth at these types of games
because if someone's gonna get really
upset ah when when you're mirroring you
against a guy playing your character it
just gets stressful but i can't wait to
see it i'm sure we're going to see lots
of shenanigans
i mean so this is i mean thing is strog
isn't it's not like he's just he is a
steve and lars main he plays them both
equally but probably goes to steve more
often so it's not exactly like this is
just a throwaway i'm just doing this for
the bands type thing like he knows how
to play this character uh we saw it
earlier with his dominant game over
galander oh late on the weekend with the
arts class
and but he gets it this time that's
something we saw him do so well against
glad it was that with punishment we're
gonna see more of that here
1.43 nice the plus frames plus four
that four
mob he has rage so one launch could be
really big for him here especially with
that new race driver last time that
first two in season four
oh and you can tell they've got each
other's timing a little bit and and as a
result it's making them back off a
little bit when they would normally go
in
now honestly nice punisher in the art
class i don't disagree with uh strokes
decision to switch to lars um you know
it was steve versus lars the first time
these two played and uh
mob did take that so let's just see how
the last goes that's his philosophy here
nice combos when the setup
look all that damage he took away and
this is looking like it is going to be
his round unless this counter changes
everything
drops the combo and down one there we go
two of the best players in russia right
now
evo online champion looking strong the
guy who took out everyone when he first
appeared on the scene
many called this to be the last two
players in the tournament not foot
they're not far off being that they've
gone very far one of them will be going
running three
nice interrupt there from mob we're
gonna see a lot of anti-last stuff here
because they both know the characters so
well
what for twos are coming up both of them
now night with punished there by strong
and he gets the combo no too many
downford ones
or breaks the throw in the middle of the
power crash is one while setting two
stroke one more round to take the first
game here and because this isn't a
losers or winners fine we are back to
first or two
action he's looking very good right now
all right again that we've punched with
uh last like strong is so good at that
that is so hard to have that unlock
ready just in case
you're not whipping this man's face you
can kind of punish that knife -14
oh but the wall messes him up okay
punishes the while 71
we've had the opposite again
there great nice punishment by mobbing
just like that final round first game
fight
i feel like the entire game is going to
go like this because back and forth
punish that well
from strog i don't know if you should
have turned around because you won't get
the water oh he's gonna go for the same
stuff that mob did earlier
oh he stayed up for the racetrack but he
gets counted okay
mob needs to make this count we are
definitely going to the wall strokes are
going to be raised no drops the clock it
up screwed it up and this could really
come back to haunt him okay welcome to
one range available
broken
one plus two back out yeah
all the mids down one three and just
like that stroke barely stays alive this
is as close as it can be right now
it's so good
this is so so good
this is this is
i was just gonna say kobe you know that
there are whiffs out there to be caught
still i can see the odd thing just being
let go here and there that if one of
them latches onto it we'll see
even more offense that was really good
oh these two are so strong
yeah i mean these two are def they're
going back and forth you know it's
literally round it's literally round for
round whoever gets the first run is
going to win the game from the way this
is going so
now it's going to be interesting to see
how they adapt to this i wonder what mob
is going to do for a stage pick here
we've seen you pick the infinite
beforehand um and one thing about the
infinite stage as well because they're
both even characters is the koreans like
to pick infinite stages because they
like to say this is just pure tekken
like there's no there's no there's no
shenanigans going on there's no walls
getting away this is pure neutral tekken
is where the the true tekken is played
so it's where they go when they believe
they're just stronger fundamentally than
their opponents so
let's see if that is what uh mob uh that
goes for it because it's gonna be true
it's gonna be a true um it's a true
mirror match right now lars versus lars
you gotta respect that view equally i
think there is a hell of a mind game in
in the wall in the wall stages that you
kind of miss out on a little bit with uh
the infinites
here we go arctic snowfall snowfall
is up to snowfall in russia as well by
the way
i think it is because i i know this is
what dragon off
um draganov has his story game against
uh master raven here
it looks like it's kind of like siberia
to me
i wouldn't be able to make that
distinction
you need to try struggling off
right down forward sounds like a dirty
thing i don't want to
whiffed
i'm back for
just small pokes right now but that oh
that could have been our last attempt
there were no strokes on point with it
today
oh
this is what i mean it's a mirror match
down back four at the same time but
mobile just slightly faster
nice nice board 44 and mob is going to
draw first blood
like i said that infinite stage you're
playing pure neutral tekken right now
what a good read that was in a great
punish as well
both of them just looking to get that
timing of their opponent
nice beacon of catching timing mob does
it there beautifully
wait these two swatch swap colors
it's i'm not even going on color anymore
i'm just going on health bar i i feel
like the first round struggles wearing
the red because
am i losing my mind
four four two
punish that nice
oh nice interrupt there from mob
excellent knows the match up like the
back of his hand and he is one run away
from tying this up
so when they played earlier in this
tournament it kind of went a bit like
this by the way it strog did win the
first game mob then won it decisively
back and then when the final game i
wonder if it's going to go like that
again
i wonder if you have to think about
characters which as well as struggle
loses me if you go straight to the steve
you thank you steve previously
the the the texas showdown right there
mexican standoff time
the best part about it is it did look
like that block hit so strong's facing
an awareness to know that it whips go
for that whiff punish he is on point
right now as he gets around on the board
[Music]
oh [ __ ] not a great punish doesn't have
the same with punishment
all right they're straight balling right
now there it is the count of the four
boards is gonna be nice damage here for
mob
bob seems to have his timing right now
[Music]
we saw that ladies running through
the harassment with it orbital
nice we've punished again by stroke
though
going for the fancy stuff no doesn't
work out he just misses it that's
something mob will do consistently rage
drive spent
maybe not the best use of rage
especially with the time left back
just like that we are all tied up
one two one in the last mirror match
yeah it didn't really get much juice out
of that rage drive not even a mix for
anything else and the other rage drive i
guess
it doesn't really do much on an infinite
you want to use it at the wall if
there's a wall break um or if you're
just doing it to to win the game so
okay what'd you do if you struggle
having watched on mob's stream when he
played shrog earlier he did um beat his
steve
uh did come back though and there were
moments with his st strong steve looked
really dominant so it's not a full gone
conclusion it's another lars mirror he
could go to steve and just have faith in
it in his main
i think i think he could go to sleep
like you said but he could also just
bring the walls back in play you saw mob
played well like mob's use of timing and
his movement and his whip punches
amazing on the infinite stage i feel
like just bringing the walls back in
place so you give him less place to move
harass him down i feel like stroga's
playing a lot better with the walls than
play but steve is always a choice you
know it just depends what he finds he is
more comfortable within the situation
um if i was him i just bring the walls
back you know it wasn't like it just it
just looked like the infinite stage is
just mob
infinitely more the most confident i've
ever seen the last play on the infinite
yeah i think he just picks the infinites
by default no matter his opponent he
seems to really like that stage let's
see what he does
gone for this steve and he's got the
internet
oh boy
okay okay that's unfortunate
the luck of the luck of the russian
there because
he gets the infinite stage steve no
not as good as the infinite stage as
well mob likes the infinite stage this
is the best case scenario for mob to end
this stroke has an uphill battle ahead
of him
waiting for his moment
probably we'll see quite a few down back
fours it's quite useful tool against
steve
crushes those
highs there we go
oh the timing and like i said with a
character like steve with the way the
russians like to play it's very timing
movement based the character c works out
so well for them
running through the classrooms
oh great whip punishment there from mob
that was immediate
as well
strong just shy of rage as well one of
the worst situations being but there is
steve one of the best race jobs in the
game can make this comeback but not with
that time mob already on the board
two rounds away from going through for
mob oh that's the situation where he
would have got more if he was playing
his last oh
very nice
bob looking so good right now
[Music]
the thing is if mob does win this he
goes in to get his revenge on the person
who put him into losers bracket
greetings
g-clef cannon so well timed there one
more hit does it nice block by strong
but this comeback is looking almost
impossible especially with outrage
i don't know if you can do this nice
locks it down back three two mob is one
round away from getting into our losers
final over stroke
drag has a mob shaped mountain to climb
is he gonna do it he would need to find
his timing and make sure he punishes
some of these whiffs
you just need to take this one round at
a time
oh goes for the low
stroke wasn't ready more low issues
peppering with the lows
nice dark
stroke half of the round is gone oh and
great whiff punish there they shouldn't
be dead especially if you
down one three one more here does it the
wow standing two mob takes it two one
over stroke to move into the losers
final
and you have you have to say this dude
that like you're saying that's that's
how it went on the winner's side right
you know mo strong takes the first game
and then mob just happens to steamroll
his way through i do think mob got lucky
that the last stage was the internet
stage which is so fun with
um
so he has so much fun with
but yeah just unfortunate for strong he
ends the tournament in fourth place but
he'll collect a bunch of points makers
claim to make it to his regional finals
later on this year um but mob his story
is not done yet he goes to lose his
final and he
hopes to get his run back over greetings
yeah great game between the two of them
you could tell just based on the
movement between the two of them alone
that they knew each other both of them
playing so well and uh yeah shame to see
strong go a lot of players favorites but
he did himself justice he played super
super well super entertaining from start
to finish i mean when you're planning to
play why in pools just to get out of
pools that's a tough tournament to play
him yeah that's the thing their pool was
what's strong mob and why you know only
two of those guys can make up and two of
those guys both of them have made it
into the top four uh here today so
let's take a look at take up the
leaderboard as it stands
um it's gonna be interesting to see
um so yes stroke so this is with their
with their finished points right now
because mob greetings and bumblebee has
seen this woman their points have not
yet been added but stroke has now put
himself uh in first place with his
performances landed in fourth um i think
struggle with an end today with third
place most likely
um third yeah third place because only
the only people left actually no fourth
because greetings
and mob are still in and those three
will probably end up making it into the
top three especially because i think uh
mob started today in eighth place so he
already have some points moving forward
so
um very good showing
you know for strong picks up 100 points
and will enter the most lucky in fourth
place and looking to make those regional
finals later on this year
that i mean given that the before this
tournament started the most points
someone had was 75 that should be enough
to go in gives him time to prepare and
think um he'll be upset there was money
to be won here and decent money as well
um but no he's done himself very proud
and he's it's been a pleasure to watch
him play because i've heard so much
about him yeah
you know he did so well here today um
i'm just
i was
really really pulling for first stroke
here today i spoke about him enough but
now now these other one i could show up
about him so chat you'll be happy with
that
um but what else you guys will also be
happy with is some merchandise for some
tekken merchandise to be available you
see greetings in this one rocking that
king you probably a fan of this shirt i
know you are still this shirt it means a
lot to you good ass tekken is the way i
like to say it and look at that shirt
it's beautiful
it's it's a really really nice shirt
please do check them out scan the code
or visit tenno dot gg uh forward slash
merch um there's really really nice
shirts there's also a law shirt as well
and there we go production thank you
yellow and black good ass tekken and uh
yeah just really really clean shirts
lovely art and uh they can deliver
anywhere i've ordered from the uk and
mine is currently in scandinavia on its
way over
are you you're saying that like someone
is going to be able to help you and be
like yeah i've got your shirt i'm
tracking it yeah i'm tracking it all the
time i love i love tracking stuff coming
from another side of the planet um this
has come from america and uh yeah no i'm
looking forward to getting it and please
do follow us online at their twitters at
bne esports youtube b any esports and
tekken twitter tech and twitch and tech
and facebook do follow us online
and thanks for buying namco
entertainment for all of the the hype
that they bring us to make sure you guys
stay up to date with all of that and i
do believe we'll be throwing you guys to
a short break but do not go anywhere
because there's some live tekken coming
up very soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the tarnished
will soon return
guided by grace
once lost
the golden order is broken
to its core
foul
tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone
extinguish
thy flame
they will fight
and they will
die in an unending curve
to be born
well
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
i command thee
brandish the elden ring
[Applause]
for all of us
it's not just our power
it's all about powers working as a team
don't underestimate me
here goes
[Music]
[Applause]
we have to work together
[Music]
[Applause]
focus
connect your minds and become one
use the red strings to save the world
you two handle the front while i take it
back
don't bother resisting i will obtain the
red strings
[Music]
um
[Music]
pretty fancy place they got here
harmony and coexistence
between the renins and the danon's
i'm
dilcarus should you need my skills on
the battlefield all i care for is
maintaining peace
i'm captain kisara of the el demencia
golf
player
from now on when i fight
i fight to protect my dream
well this crew just gets bigger and
bigger
the renans
seems the rumors you were running with
them were true
been looking for you
oh get the hell out of my realm
this is tannen's realm and it's ours
understand
is it over
it's only just begun
welcome back to the toc is the eu east
but before we get back into it what do
you think about all that i mean tells
the rise coming out worse than in less
than a week now uh september 10th
looking really good i mean for me of
those three games elden ring george r
martin's got involved it looks beautiful
like i i can't wait for that game to
come out i'm definitely getting that
yeah i
am i'm really excited for elden ring um
i can't wait for that one this coming
top of next year i believe um and
scarlet nexus i still need to pick up i
was going to pick up like a month ago
then i completely forgot about so i will
eventually do that and you guys better
do that as well what you guys can also
do is have a big uh support shout out
for our astro the official mix-up and
headset the tekken online challenge
always supporting tekken and all tech
and events so we do appreciate all the
support they they give towards us and
also a huge shout out to bandai namco
entertainment for providing us you know
with those uh quality games and
obviously the tekken we have here in
front of you right now
absolutely well
let's get ourselves ready for the final
parts of the action we have
a losers final that's looking very juicy
head greetings versus mob and then that
grand final waiting there bumblebee
who's played out of his skin let's be
honest i mean it's been so good all the
way through adapted very very well
uh it's looking like a very strong final
three
i mean this is a run back for mob this
is the person who put him into the
loosest bracket in convincing fashion
six rounds straight couldn't get going
at all so he's definitely gonna want to
avenge that loss and uh for greetings as
well you know he's one going to have
another shot bumblebee because he could
have done it it did go to a final game
final round he just
fell at the final hurdle uh and he could
have taken it but he didn't so be
interested to see that i do want to see
um i probably want to see mob win just
to get more verse bumble because we
haven't seen that yet and um as someone
told me once i think bumblebee once won
a a huge russian tournament pretty
recently and he won it over both mob and
strong uh
someone be able to correct me if i'm
wrong but he was he was able to do that
offline
so
but this will be just another knot on
the bomb boost but we can do it again
but before that we do have greetings
versus mob we're starting off in the
island paradise what about the music on
this stage uh let's do when they the
kids upstairs then they go down dude i
absolutely love it
this this for me is this stage is like
an ode to tekken 4
the wondrous days of tekken's like batsu
combo videos
with deru playing all over it like this
is just a beautiful stage uh i'd love to
see more stages like this there's some
you know
this versus g g corp helipad at night i
mean really is there even a comparison
shove straight away oh strap into back
one two though very interesting
how many king players do the new back
three the hulk hogan loads up off of it
now it's so good because you get back to
nokia as well if you go for it and the
just frame isn't really much of a just
frame it's worth going for it all four
again greetings starting off on the
front foot against mob maybe he has his
number that's what punished punish that
oh okay
goes to the unblockable greetings is
having none of it with their downford
one
now cracking him in the skull for even
trying it i like it down forward two
regular throw broken
for a huge ddt but nice block but no
launch by greetings the curse of the
king player is to do a while standing
two two when you should launch
stop that that was a great step on the
dynamic entry and we're going to the
wall as well
shiny wizard
all right this is mob's chance should be
able to go to the wall but doesn't want
to new razor he can break the balcony
i think he does that use his tailspin
yes it did though
oh the raw unblockable but he catches
him floated
mob is angry right now but it's not
enough to win in the round
that's the great thing about kings at
forward three if you go for it and you
get jabbed out of it you're at a weird
angle there's not much they can do it's
such a good round ending
okay a mob should be able to carry to
the no again goes for the spike regular
throw not broken that's huge for mob
what's the follow up here
nice patience by greetings
one two
yep okay doesn't get the wall
regular throat broken
oh big whipper not the best punishment
yeah while setting two ones season four
buff the second it is now a count to hit
launcher
i just say i hate that by the way so
many strings the second it just has to
become accounting launcher
all the second hits are mid where it
used to be a high that's that's
challenging yeah that lasts this down
for two one yeah
speak of the devil
there it is okay regular thrown up
even when you scuff it goes for the good
okey doesn't quite work out
okay looks like it could go to final
round number four regular throw broken
this time raider and all the greetings
nice interrupts doesn't want to take the
throw
two one doubled one nice nice there by
mob he's alive
patience here from uh greetings for four
neutral two
four four two from large yes the county
should carry to the wall as well yes he
does
all right let's go for the fancy combos
again the ford four two gets the wall
splat very nice by mob
not gonna kill her but he can put
himself in a killing situation running
three
now good one this is looking like mobs
round back one keep out
has to do so much here i get the thing
you might go for a chain grab oh no
muscles
dead
look at the wave dash by greetings
really strong movement still wasn't
enough
what a game though that was great
i mean mob look this has been mobs
factor we've seen it so well it's just
his adaptation that was a mid-game
adaptation there but early we start
against stroke losing that first game
goes to the infinite starts making the
comeback knows what he needs to do moves
around him well now in this game just
mid game realizes what he needs to do
switches it up makes greetings come to
him and he takes his first i mean he got
his first round on greetings earlier but
now he has his first game over greetings
and it's a great start here in this
losers final
yep looked very strong had made some
really good guesses at the wall and also
i think we saw it a little bit when
greeting was playing its kuna mitsu
before he gets bumblebee there were a
few times where he got hit with a
one-two and he was caught pressing
buttons straight again after trying to
steal his turn back and i got got the
thing that mob uh caught onto that and
started uh locking him down even more um
i don't i don't think greetings
greetings needs to change much though he
played pretty damn well yep it just came
down to mob in the end just you know
getting going whoever whoever gets
started first that's been the 10 of the
tape for today in general whoever gets
started going first is the one who
normally takes the round so if you
interest see the uh the adaptation here
we're probably going to see the
forgotten realm again
um because you know we've seen how much
greetings like that and there it is
there it is
it hasn't always worked out though from
the perspective of getting the floor
breaks we haven't seen a single like big
floor break juggle or anything like that
really for him so
uh is it going to come back to bite him
i guess we'll see
last is okay on this stage too
so we we saw this earlier with bumblebee
lars
small mobs uh job here so just kind of
break the floors before greetings does
every launch every touch every
opportunity he gets he just wants to
take away that voice but the first one
is going to go to greetings
oh it may do oh no yes he keeps it he
went big he went for the head foot on
the wall the wall throws um if he'd done
that then he would have gone through the
floor again okay double two one yep
breaks the first floor very smart
water like it
oh catches green pushing buns should
have tried to break the floor but it's
okay
nice in the back very nice there mob
being very aggressive now forcing the
issue
and again it ends out very nice start
there by mob with the down two one
great low power again
my election is he gonna do it this time
okay this time he breaks the floor i
assume he was keeping it last time
because he just wants more damaging
options with the floor break right yeah
i think so yeah and he did try and break
it with the wall throw but if your
opponent's aware of that on this stage
again it comes back to the fact that
you're making your options about the
stage rather than about what the
opponent's thinking
very patient play from greetings here
oh my goodness the 442 though expect him
to say that doesn't work out
nice the lightning screw out of nowhere
i respect the attempt but doesn't work
out this time
if you're gonna do it you might as well
do it with zero health
running through the first frames
and there's plus frames
oh tried to whip on it doesn't work out
shiny instantly not broken
wow
yeah broken shining wizard into the
giant swing mob was aware of it walking
back now are we seeing a decent
there's something funky is going on
right now
i don't know
this video could be a
i don't know something funky is
happening maybe mob's playing the mind
games right now as the life deficit this
is risky though with the life deficit
not doing anything
i think it's an odd decision to just
stand there and do nothing and just like
their greetings will take the round
let's see what happens this round looked
like it was a decent to me
i don't know mobs just walking back
maybe we i think we might have some kind
of hardware issues
uh between the two um i believe mob
plays on stick could be some stick
issues from what was going on there like
he was just holding back i don't know
we'll be getting something uh
concrete for you guys soon and we'll
find out what happens but yeah i mean
we're seeing already um i like what
greetings is trying to do you know when
he's getting low parries on that stage
he's electing to go for as much damage
as possible to make those floor breaks
count um i did want to see mob sort of
uh play it put more emphasis into the
break from the floors
um rather than just like getting the
damage because king is so good he's so
good on the stage so yes yeah i agree
with you yeah and mob does you sick he
uses the same stick as me and without
plugging that stick i'll say it's as
sturdy as an astro headset so
oh what's going on are they back in
i think so it's the final round
find a round situation
and this could be the round shoulder i
don't know
no yes he gets him okay so we did have a
desync we switched to backup production
standards here we get you the game no
matter what and we get you the result
wow okay
that
phenomenal all right okay
this this is this is when we know we're
in the absolute peak of online tech and
production standards is that we still
managed to get the result at the last
second
and it looks like he took it
we had we had a situation like that once
in icfc uh in a final round situation
um
the game because obviously because you
have two people in the dobby one is the
backup and then one is the actual uh
what was seeing the stream from uh we
stopped on one the there was a desync on
one of the on the regular ones was oh we
can't see anymore and production
switched to the backup like straight
away and as i always see the gaming
right right immediately so production is
really on point when it comes to these
things this is the future
of uh of second you know or online
viewing experience you know like you
still get the result and just like that
uh it is now all tied up 1-1
uh
i'm it's it's a bit jarring so i'm
trying to figure out like what happened
there
we're just going to see stage ping pong
surely now that's what it's going to
come down to
we're going to go infinite uh back to
the realm infinite maybe again realm
again depending on how it goes surely
that's how it's going to play out now
yeah especially it's going to be the the
infinite going around infinitely going
around into the scroll realm until it's
over so whoever wins this next game puts
himself in a great position because if
it does go down to a final game they
will pick where the final match happened
but we've seen on that game there mob is
still pretty confident and comfortable
on the forgotten realm you know he knows
what he's doing is using like back uh
backboards he wants to break the floor
and stuff like he's just he's ready for
it so
it'll be interesting to see how how they
make the adaptations throughout the
stages you know because the first thing
was island paradise and when you break
the balcony of island paradise it is a
very big stage i think it's
i think it's the
i think between that stage and the
broken uh wall and you know when you
break you break the break the balcony
and then break the wall and jungle that
pose i think those are two of the
biggest stages in the entire game those
broken floors um so it almost simulates
the infinite stage for a but you get to
see with all that movement around how
much you can play with it so
mob had time to
uh to gather data on how the big stage
the almost infinite works out for him so
let's just see what he chooses here does
he stick with his tried and true
infinite yes he does the art of snowfall
the russian stage that's one it's one a
piece but i think it's an arguable that
mob has made better use of the infinite
stage over recent games than uh
greetings has made of the the the floor
break stage i think
he won that game but he didn't get many
of the breaks that we saw whilst we were
watching the game
um so i would say the the momentum for
me despite uh just losing that game by a
hair
it is with mob yeah i do have to agree i
feel like uh greetings almost picks like
the infinite stage sorry the forgotten
realm as like a default pick it's what
you're supposed to pick as the king
player rather than having stuff ready
for it
nice just frame gets okay went for the
forward two you can get so much from
that scenario
oh this is that nice
relatively even unhealthier we're gonna
throw broken
we're gonna throw broken right back
definitely a scuffed shiny wizard
oh lovely duck into launch
that was incredibly quick what's the
okay no i don't
yeah he was ready for that great art
boss
just trading a little bit here
two running
follow up
that knee is not plus despite looking
like it it's great g clef cannon right
there by mob
nice stuff
it should be the round for lmg more very
nice
look at this he's so he just plays so
well on that infinite stage he does he's
speed he's speed running him right now
oh doesn't break the giant swing no
as he is
we take this
nice punish
he's taking a page out of strokes book
with those art blasts
blocking him down with the jabs
i punish
great low parry there by greetings and
this could be the round if he plays this
right it should be
okay
gets on the board was looking very
one-sided up till then
oh my god there's another one
has he got a read on him
robert's not breaking these drag swings
oh no
pick up take it back break it back break
it back no no okay
back one two
greetings making the comeback here
we see mob doing this
[Music]
nice break one plus two throws
knee no punish by mob though
[Music]
oh didn't commit
okay the race drive gets the flow
yeah that wasn't the best situation
though
mob can take this running explode off
nine seconds left
can greetings steal this one
five seconds the while 72 is getting
back
two seconds down back through the
orbital back that's gonna wait here it's
timer
oh
that was
there was still time
dirty wizard we still have to commentate
this
one third one
that one two punish that
it's very important to duck that second
hit and get a launch
oh break jazz swing this time start
breaking one
nice delay
oh blast not working out i'm back to
but the cameraman's not his friend nice
break on the throw
[Music]
running three
okay i'm just how these guys are getting
nervous now overall
okay 12 seconds left
we're not going to see a repeat are we
surely not
surely not
for the tank i could have locked him up
five seconds four seconds left running
forward down back four two seconds oh
yeah that was the wrong time for that
move
and
with two more seconds on the clock that
would have won in the game
but wow
it was interesting i wonder what he was
going for
it was just the wrong time for that that
i mean any throw because king king's
throws do take a while like even we did
something like tombstone especially like
muscle buster there wouldn't have been
enough time the clock was ticking down
and you wouldn't have enough time maybe
like maybe tijuana twist would have
worked but
would have definitely got him but that
would be that definitely wasn't the
input he was going for i actually can't
think what he was going for there if it
wasn't that's right um so interesting
enough time
for him to uh to close it out there and
take it so yes 2-1 now to lmg mob but
greetings is keeping us very close we're
probably going to go back to the
forgotten realm but
i'm i'm excited so excited at this point
greetings is making this one a real game
he really is and he hasn't even done one
tombstone into max damage juggle on
forgotten realm he hasn't done one
muscle buster into max damage there's
this the law of averages says it's gonna
happen i wonder if it's gonna happen
this next game these games have been
closer than than i would have expected
on their native stages we just we caught
the end of that forgotten realm state
match it was a sliver of health that
game went down to the absolute wire as
well we've been really in for a treat
from these guys
now here is the forgotten realm
bob has a job ahead of him if he can win
this game your huge statement exactly
what he needs to do
all right if i'm in mob shoes it isn't
the worst it isn't the worst case
scenario
because even if you lose this we go back
to the infant and we have seen mob so
constant on the infinite stage our plane
is strong on the infinite stage in the
mirror and against the steve so
greetings is really the one who has to
force the issue right now
again i love chat we must have had some
problems
punish that
not broken to the wall yes
nice
oh oh no no no no no no no
no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no does
this surely won't do it break the floor
oh my god yeah he cannot dead no i will
break again
i think honestly i think i think too
many hits i think if if mob did less
hits in that combo and then spiked uh
that was guaranteed but mob doesn't let
that face him down four two one
all the fancy combos you love to see it
i love the way the mob's been using jab
and down forward one just to lock down
the movement and stop all the chain
grabs being really good
taking a page out of strokes break to
throw this time
oh but the hot knee doesn't can this is
gonna be around two rounds up for
greetings he's playing this stage so
well
he is indeed but we saw it in the last
game anything can happen you can come
back oh it doesn't convert it into a
battery really needed to do that that
would have put him in a prime position
or three looking good breaks a giant
swing that was important super important
that's dark mob should have this round
downward one and that's the while 72
he's staying alive right now
these two are giving us one hell of a
game right now
mob needs two rounds to end it greetings
needs one more round just to elongate it
just for one more game there's a lot of
water response
i start close
what you want no doubt
all right one two
four three
i like this it's going for the shove
slows them down a little bit every time
you shove them you're slowing them down
again
again needs to switch it up they're
becoming a little bit predictable oh
giant sweet again that would have been
dead nice break
finish is it i like that option break
the floor immediately as well no more
flaws left in play so smart by mob even
if the combo isn't the best but big one
available
no it doesn't use it
okay
i've got one g-clef doesn't finish it
oh my goodness oh my god oh my god he
crushed a mid but it was he was airborne
it didn't get anything he was airborne
four seconds you need something big that
he can't do it
budget hell sweet
you know what
i
i knew he would do ford ford for three
there i feel like that was the obvious
choice to go for you need a big mid but
you need a big low you need big damage
to go for he should have just done
another low i think i think he should
have just kept the lows coming because
he had nothing to lose and oh my
goodness he got very unfortunate he did
the lightnings through when went
underwater upward as i went on the board
four but because it was floated he
couldn't get a combo maybe he did whilst
any four i don't know
um but yeah that was that was insane and
now we have a final game between
greetings and mob
way closer than their winner semi-final
match way closer i've got i've got to
disagree with you he was foot
unfortunate without four or three i mean
come on
it pushed forward four
i mean how on earth does it crush that
listen that move goes under literally
all of my mids so i'm not surprised it's
time for it it's time for other people
to to go what i do feel that pain yeah
i'll get it i get it
yeah that was a surprise i think he even
surprised himself or maybe that was why
he didn't fully convert it he did
i think whilst that informed me the
problem is because he was floated that's
not a situation you get very often a
float using a lightning screw so maybe
he was just expecting oh my regular he
just did what he regular combo maybe he
didn't think he was floating i don't
know um while 74 was the smartest option
to go for because obviously it's the the
most uh they've got the biggest hitbox
of all the moves the lowest hitbox as
well so it could have worked
unfortunately it is fine because mob
goes back to his patented arctic
snowfall and he plays so well on this
stage
sweaty palms and squeaky bums it's gonna
be two all one of these guys is going
out and the other one is going through
to the finals
all right they're down back four
again four four three plus four on here
big chunky move
nice instant shiny wizard very strong at
that
power
one or two get some float again
a rage available for greetings just one
touch and that could have been it
round two
he'll be frustrated there unfortunate
down four two into giant swings broken
again needs to mix these things up and
he does
oh but a full crash downpour too the
first time that has counted all day but
no drops the combo
nice [ __ ] full crash though
what you should do now if you're mob
three
now four
doesn't finish
in the final game
this is it the winner of this game
whoever gets two more rounds moves into
grand finals on the loser's side secures
themselves 200 points minimum moving
forward on the leaderboard g clef cannon
oh look at this now mob is feeding
himself the shadow step is coming in oh
[ __ ]
oh the step into the start orbital very
nice i think this is the round as well
for mob this is
this is this set point right now for mob
to grand finals lose the side carried
him into tekken tax three unbelievable
now he's got two rounds to win this or
he's going to be going out
punish that
1.43 again greetings is not blocking
that at all while standing 2-1 back four
count hit but it's a trade no throwing
it
that'll be it surely
mob all aggression while sending 2-1
ends it out and mob moves into grand
finals losers side
what a game what a treat those guys gave
us as well what an unbelievable game
some really clever play from both of
them they didn't let either of them run
away with it with their own stage um
what a great performance and greetings
will be going out with 150 points that's
a that's a big chunk a big old chunk
that also came down to mob just what he
you saw those final two rounds he just
got his aggression going everything was
going he just made written second guess
himself and closing out with the while
721 count here
he was just completely ready for
everything uh great string there for mob
and
you know he he has a he has a a job in
front of him now you know he was the
evil online champion that was one thing
now he has to win the toc as well this
is the master's event this is huge this
is the big one
um
and this this right here
is that natural
addie kicker doesn't move
uh i don't think it is yeah i don't
think that's natural i actually think
mob could have blocked there
so
very surprising finish and you could
like if a player is doing that if a
player is
they're literally just slamming the
buttons with deal like they're getting
palaces on their hands hitting the
buttons like when the king player is
doing that they're nervous he probably
expected more ali kicks i'm thinking
rather than anything
but what you guys should expect is more
tech connection if you look at the
online master events we have still a few
more coming tomorrow will be west africa
followed by south africa middle east
south asia southeast asia philippines
oceana korea and japan and when all
that's finished at the end of uh next
month the regional plans will begin in
november starting with south africa and
ending in north america in january of
2022 oh my goodness the time moves so
fast um 2021 just begun in my head um
but yeah still 2019 isn't it isn't it
the 2019
tour that's what i think but that that
thing up there nothing upstairs is 2021
so i don't know what's going on here
um so yeah so mob
can actually do a repeat here he can do
something that's super committed over in
west europe zubrican was the winner of
eva west online and then and then he won
the toc
eu west
and he did both of those from the losers
bracket can mob do this one from this
record in the same fashion as super
humor there'll be one way to find out uh
what you guys can also find out about is
some tekken merchandise oh what a link
i'm providing you with you saw king
earlier with her greetings you got king
on the shirt i feel like we should send
him one for free just for a showing here
today can we do that guys can we send
him a free king shirt
all right they said no sorry no stop no
stop i tried greetings i really did
sorry they they told me no
um but yeah you can buy one instead
greetings you know if you use the qr
code or use the tenno dot gg slash merch
go into that website and get one i see
the law one is available as well in the
black and yellow the lore color or the
bruce lee colors as well so
yeah this has been some great tech in
here today and we aren't finished
we're not done
we're not done and i know mob
wants this to last a long time the
longer it lasts the better his chances
are
he's got a he's got a bit of a hill to
climb but he's got to be super confident
he's just one evo east eastern europe
and very recently as well
and i watched him play and he played so
well then all right you say that you say
he should be super confident but i
mentioned it earlier bumblebee recently
won an offline russian tournament it was
a big tournament over stroke and mob
the top two in russia for the most
possible players that mickey out there
as well but those are the those are the
two most visible top players out there
in russia and bombay took both of them
out to win that now
like you said i you could be confident
but this was offline this was this was
where you know every everything is on
point you haven't the excuses
you can't make as many excuses out there
and that's why he lost clean
so it's going to be interesting to see
how as mob made his his adjustments to
the applications because bumblebee
i mean we know exactly how this is going
to go it with bumblebee he needs to get
his aggression started first if he does
it is
it is over for his opponent we need to
see the the kinematsu antsy play from
uh mob if we don't see that this can be
a very quick game if we do
mob will uh defend josie never mind i
lied
interesting pick very interesting pick
is he is he already free rolling with
his uh extra life that's an interesting
choice
so of course you know mob has to win two
first two threes to win this
uh which does give your opponent uh and
winners more time to to play around with
ideas to try things out
and uh he's picking josie straight from
the off
i do think he is taking liberties with
his extra life
um we saw kanemitsu the whole way except
for that one time he picked ling it
didn't work out um i do think he's
probably taking liberty to that extra
life
um i think i'm going to try jersey see
how that works
so i mean winning a game with josie with
a the character isn't your main is a big
statement
nice lock on the wall bongos
nice patience yeah very hard for mob to
get in right now and they're the big
superman punch
punch the gun
nice start here by bomb
nice punish i think you have up to 14 or
15 frames to punish
the war bongos before switch one will
punish you
[Music]
very nice
finishes it gets caught counter hit
though this will hurt a lot
yeah
mix up rage drive spent
cd2 not the best punish but downpour one
you could kill with the punishment okay
still alive
[Music]
running through the flash frames running
through the flash frames oh the
okay butterflies
oh
cd3s are coming off the ball ready yeah
just harassing the legs
[Music]
one two nice punish
spent and nice bumblebee
oh
are we seeing it again it looks like we
could have another dc oh but we switched
immediately to the back of you guys see
this level of production you didn't miss
anything
i feel like production need their own
set of commentators talking about how
good they are that's absolutely crazy
thank you guys i stuck there on the
switch one
oh down 42.
i'm back again the elbow nice stuck on
switch one
raise drive nice stop
this is one way to bring it back this
won't be dead but this is a nice start
what's the mixer it'll go in surely
wow big 442 there by mob
[Music]
gonna be just doing nothing right now
letting more play in his face this is
what he likes
nobody can switch one this time that's
all
down back number four
here we go
nice g clef cannon
jabs
i'll be just shy of rage right now there
it is back four
big challenge rage available 20 seconds
left
that didn't hit okay let's be honest mob
even you actually want to say that
didn't touch that range oh that didn't
look like it didn't hit that did not hit
did not don't believe that
um but anyway
great starting here replay so who knows
can you find out
i think they both press buttons at the
same time
yeah that's why it hit what probably
happened there is uh
uh bumblebee probably pushed the button
and when you push a bite in second it
extends your heart box
so things that look like they shouldn't
hit they here that's probably what
happened now unfortunate um for um
bumblebee but you know that's mob going
up first game looking strong and even
even though we said it could have been a
throwaway pick but josie didn't look
terrible you know he might stick to the
final round could have gone all the way
so yeah i liked that i did actually just
like the josie it might even be a
counterfeit forum
for
mob because you play bomb he's played
canada the whole time these two are
probably played back and forth a lot of
times someone in chat said earlier that
um uh mob actually taught bumblebee so
you know that's um all right there's
gonna be history between these two so
maybe josie is the character that
normally works out them when they play
and maybe just struggles with kuni mitsu
interesting interesting i think well the
other thing that we maybe didn't call
out enough there was that they got their
under the infinite stage straight off
the bat
which obviously helped mob uh big time
uh so yeah i wouldn't forgive him
picking josie again he was much better
than i expected him to be and it didn't
look like he wasn't sure of himself yeah
again
not a bad decision
yeah it's interesting because in some in
some ways this is great for lars on one
axis because he can just carry from
tekken 2 to tekken tag tournament 5
all the way across but then on the other
axis it's a very very short range stage
and if he keeps him in within that rage
he's gonna lock down a lot of that carry
you really escalate a lot of the seconds
that last carries you through fight
[Music]
that fall
oh nice cd through gets the card
great start here by bubbly warbon goes
nice he stays ducking but no launch
let's finish the string this should be
the round nice wait for this game
fight
[Music]
nearly got a big big one there
i'm back
now i'm about to get the count here very
nice
this does so much we going all the way
back we'll get to the windows that mob
knew that was coming as well
i start here mob this is definitely his
round no way in hell that he loses this
round absolutely impossible for mob to
lose this round of tekken in front of
him right now all he needs is one more
hit and mob is going to win this
completely unusable round that there is
with the downford one
you are trying so hard to curse yourself
aren't you i'm not
forcing you staying obvious right
nice to pull over kick
well one thing we're not seeing from
obviously we're fun isn't the best right
now not getting full launches on things
making things work punishment is really
lacking right now but it doesn't matter
because he's still ahead
not right now though down forward four
nice there from bumble and buff
it's all good stepping but you've also
got to pull the trigger when it's your
turn
oh
i wasn't confident that that was gonna
be the punish there
someone for this way back in step and
that's the fourth one plus two team from
nowhere nice while 72-1
great break there by bombing
final round again for the second time
the josie even though he's he's not
i mean i say he hasn't he didn't win the
first game josie's looking strong right
now and staying very competitive
fully agree fully agree
again it look it looks like two people
who know each other who have similar
timing yeah that was a great duck there
by bombido but no messes up the combo
i quite get the count hit nice slides
into some stuff
doesn't pull the trigger on the online
special great duck on twos oh you don't
see that very often
cd3
rage available for bumblebee
standing three two finishes the string
and downpour four bomb bumblebee we're
all tied up now in the josie not looking
too bad right now
not at all not at all and that damn
football was so smart it just locked
down every single option he had yeah
whether he you know i've noticed that he
if he's going to go for the lightning
screw he's going to do it when he's on
zero health it doesn't really matter
anyway and of course he had the rage
drive but it locked down at every single
option
uh so yeah great great finish that that
round and yeah
as you say it's actually looking like a
pretty good choice
that's the thing as well you know when
two people who play all the time in this
situation you're going to see the weird
things you're going to see something
certainly you're not used to because
they're just so used to each other um
like they're just they do weird things
you don't expect this they're going to
throw out some random which you don't
expect people to there are and then you
know they end up just you know
winning because of it so that's just
what happens you have to start hiding
some secret straps when you play against
someone you're so close to
um but yeah josie you know that is the
the name of the day right now it's also
characters you don't see very often if
we're being honest you know josie's
really a lot of jersey players have just
sort of moved on you know when it came
to season four you know they don't
really play the character anymore you
know playing other characters chicken
mara for example in the best josie's in
the world one of the best in europe you
know switched to marduk and lydia now um
you know players like poke chop are
playing uh negan and and [ __ ] rum
just uh blackbeard playing you know
lydia and konimitsu now you know josie's
arena as well yeah there's he just kind
of fallen by the wayside right now um
but yeah just brings in the infinite
stage very smart
um it's where he is the best
uh
uh from what we've seen throughout the
day
it's where he's home
and i just get the thing this could just
go back and forth again we could be
playing stage ping pong
it's got to be cyber area
i'm just thinking you just think about
the location again
oh yeah i want to go there looks good
hold it for one plus two to
what a start
less than 10 seconds in and mob is
already in rage
nice g clef kind of that's something
he's doing very often down for one it's
g club cannon
throws out again
oh wrestling no brokenness ball be
throwing this round away
okay that is insane down forward one
into g clef cannon is literally one mob
that entire round but i just thought oh
great punisher for bumby by the way um a
reason why josie's getting this match up
basically all of lars's lows are going
to be launched punishable
yeah of course
um that was such an emphatic start to
that last round they did with a loss
that was crazy
he just downpoured one into g clef
cannon like he's just not
he's just not pushing the right buttons
oh big down two gets the counter and the
pickup as well
this isn't going to be dead is he going
to use rage though yes he is oh he is
interesting choice sure i mean surely
he's going to leave him with he's not
going to be dead he has too much health
what's the follow-up though oh great
patience
excellent patience there from bumblebee
to make the the gel kick whiff and just
a simple punch of downfall for that
spacing was absolutely superb
cd3 mind your ankles
there's a lot of momentum going back and
forth here yeah
great little harry there excellent
scouting by bumblebee
[Music]
bongos doesn't work out this time but
nice ford one plus two what's the
follow-up
mix-up
okay new race drive
he shot back oh no
bob is really clawing at everything
right now
great block on the floor forward four
bumblebee is active
that is a hell of a read he was
shuffling right up in his grill that was
a crazy crazy read oh and a big counter
here to start off right now for
bumblebee we criticize the josie pick
out first but it's doing so much damage
with a huge crush
this is gonna put bubble uh mob in rage
oh nice
but can't get the combo he thought it
was a regular magic four it was a float
race drive spent
now one nice g cliff cannon
443 the plus frames rage available
on one we'll do it again surely he's
drive forward four into switch three the
first time he's done that low the entire
set
that that is that is taken
guys tekken jesus jesus louise
we've just gone from the slowest game of
tekken i have ever seen in my life at
the start of this tournament honestly i
thought i could take a nap at one point
and then that game was absolutely insane
the adrenaline that i was feeling
watching that game the momentum and the
way it was shifting these guys played so
fast i just love that these guys are
capable of switching gears so heavily
the fact that bumblebee opened up so
fast and those crashed as twos were all
hitting that was just great awareness
and realizing where he wants the duck
also great reads on the lows you know
that find that round before the final
four four four three that was an
excellent block there by bumblebee um
i i was gonna criticize him for being
too passive before going into that game
but now he's just decided i don't get to
i don't deserve to criticize him
apparently with the way he just sped
through that round so you know this is
potential final game right now mob
i think that's the first time we've seen
him lose on the internet stage here
today well he lost earlier to greetings
but that's
not like that you know like that was
just
he just looked like he was getting
completely outplayed by anything but the
fact that he saved the the switch three
for then the first time he's used that
low the entire the first time he's used
a low out of switch the entire set just
so smart and we move into bomby's
potential final game tournament game
here for bombay if he wins this he'll be
the toc eu east champion but mob
definitely has something to say about
that
no doubt whatsoever starts with a bolt
smash doesn't get anything off it goes
in for g clef he's got a loss off that
definitely
actually when he does it off down
forward one i mean bumpy just isn't
playing around it correctly but there
again another dd2 and no he wanted to
keep the tail spin there i respected a
nice punisher on the three two nice
punishment ukemi great low parry this
could be the start of something
spends tell spin early this time gonna
break the no he wanted to break the
balcony that's so unfortunate but we're
punished that could have been huge
three three
oh this way back oh but it was a down
jab so it didn't work
i need to be the plus frames the plus
frames
and then battle
g again down forward one time down
forward one g clef cannon he isn't ready
okay war bond goes yeah one goes again
into the switch three this time
all this pressure
it's threatening now
nice we're punished
mobbing rage
great low parry patience and great low
parry but he wanted a big combo there to
kill
regular broken three
on back
back one big and that's guaranteed if he
back for a bump he needed to stay down
and mob has finally got some control
back
he has and he's doing it not an infinite
stage yeah stealing it stealing his turn
back so to speak
nice punishment down for
before we two into switch one
both of them percy close to that balcony
[Music]
we'll cross down football big low nice
blocking
and the ford ford four he can't block it
this time and we are going to a final
game right now and bumblebee has a huge
decision ahead of him right now
you know you the josie has done so well
that game before josie and if it was so
good it just just really locked down mob
he's shown why the character is good you
know and that's the thing all basically
all those that lars does are launched
punch for josie so it is a smart pick
and it is really paying dividends with
punishment for one plus two is on point
but
is it time to bring out kenny mitsu
because this is this is it this is the
reset or the tournament on the line here
they say so taking his chest on speed
and uh wouldn't it be the ultimate
checkmate to actually go back to an
infinite stage
okay whis i'm talking to you on a
private line don't pull faces whilst i'm
commenting
until they got rid of it and they
replaced it with discord i'm not even
gonna go into that it's some boomer
reference okay then
too young to understand apparently
uh as you keep reminding me i honestly i
don't think the infinite stage would be
a bad pick it would be the ultimate
check mate if you actually beat him
again on the infinite stage but there
are other options i think just complete
this set with josie just just see it out
see it out
i mean that's the one thing and then
it's you know what what is the stage
pick you know you know we know mob loves
the infinite but you did win on the
internet stage just uh just before that
you know you kind of dominated him so
it character or stage it's your choice
bumblebee what are you doing
he's gone for the infinite himself
i like it i like it
this is the ultimate baller decision i
love it i absolutely love it
here we go
get ready guys this could be your final
game of the day
cd3
this is a great start here from
bumblebee but he needs more
nice block but no punishment to switch
through
oh no he's just taken to me wrestling
that's not even natural i don't know
what bumblebee's doing he's falling
apart right now no punish there raise
drafts already
it's just looking a bit desperate now
for bumblebee no resources for the
comeback
the only reason he's got his time he's
got 30 seconds to do this he doesn't
need to rush it running three
and the forward forward for again i have
to respect mob as well for doing that
after the whale was blocked emphatically
in the two games beforehand
okay but big counter to start with
[Music]
[Music]
patience here oh even on life
all the time
okay
[Music]
dude he knows not to finish at that time
the air for not broken
and the shoulder the back throw mob one
round away from resetting the bracket
here today
and this is five rounds straight enough
for mob he has all of the momentum in
his favor
nice power power crush wood board two
look at this momentum now
oh
loses this round he only has himself to
blame running three fully agree
he's got rage yeah he's some static
movement here one forward one plus two
could change this entire game
raise your hand spent
race drive spent on the other side
downfall slash
three four of range
oh
cd
ten seconds eleven
standing three the keep out oh and look
at that look the cheeky low there from
mob as he now resets the bracket and i
have to say momentum is all in mob's
favor right now
yeah you can't doubt it the foot sees as
well the spacing on that there's no
doubt that one here that was just
absolutely perfectly spaced yeah and
that's what you get when you play a
character as much as he clearly has
that's just so scary when you think
about because mob that was six rounds
straight the walls weren't played in the
infinite he's really nullified it and
now
this is a tough choice now for bumblebee
does josie work that well at some point
you know joseph was doing a job
then when he went to the the if you can
go to what i'm hearing is that mob does
very well against kinimitsu he knows the
character very well so that's why he
might also shy away from picking the
character by there's a time to pick the
maintenance now you go just try it see
how it goes
i don't know i'm i'm this
please i'm with you i'm with you i mean
i actually i think for many players
when you switch between characters
there's almost a round or two you may
chuck away getting yourself reacquainted
with the spacing and the movement and
the
uh the the natural fundies of the
character you're using and you kind of
can give away a round or two in the
exchange
so if he's going to make that decision
to change i feel like he should do it
sooner rather than later
no he's sticking with the jersey is
committed i think one he had a plan
uh he he had a plan going to josie like
i mentioned earlier all the low pack all
the lows basically all losses loaded
punishable for josie a smart decision
and two someone say people are telling
me that you know mob does very well
against queen unitsu so he just wants to
say that stay away from that
the beautiful you know the cereal oh a
magic falls right off the bat
okay oh he could have had some crazy
stuff there in the back though didn't
commit to it could have had a launch
it's the wall splat knife picks up off
the wall i'm gonna break the balcony yes
he is i don't know if this is dead
though
see you three one more here does it a
down four nice ends it with a safe love
round two
fight
nice duck
full string hits again i don't know why
he's a natural i don't know what bumpy's
doing it's the same with g clef he's
just getting hit by the full thing
[Music]
again doesn't finish the last hit though
punish that no that could have been
launched for josie that could have been
launched for josie
oh
boy
those were two launch opportunities that
went as a ride there for bumblebee
nice low parry
how far is it going to take him
very nice indeed
that's a big chunk for a low parry
[Music]
cd3 is getting started
ah but this the down back four count
here
oh that was just complete mix there by
mob new exact ability to adjust
when when he doesn't get the juggle that
he he should be getting because of the
wall weird angles all of that stuff is
so good
nice just die stuck just cools out the
magic we're gonna be a side wall though
oh my goodness just mob is completely
mixing bumpy right now he knows exactly
when he wants the duck
carries to the wall as well
cd3
this can be the start
big power crush
guaranteed
i mean this is a great start right now
for mob racket reset
and he goes up and
what's that
i know i know bumblebee got around there
but without that round there'll be like
nine rounds straight
yeah it was dominant it was it was
dominant i think
i think ultimately
his mob's ability to just convert any
unusual random situation that you get in
a 3d fighting game to the maximum damage
that he can possibly get and the mix-up
is just too good right now
um and so a lot of that will come down
to the fact that he's clearly played
probably 10 20 000 games of player
matches with this character he's seen
every single scenario with his charac
with his character
big body small bodies weird stage
interactions and he's just able to
convert every single one of them
yeah i do think if there's a time to
pull out kidding me to us now
yeah it feels like mob is now prepared
it feels like he's got everything done
he's he's warmed up into the set
uh winning the infinite winning on the
wall stage like it doesn't matter to him
right now so
um i'm hoping that that i feel like now
is the time to pull out the commits to
at least give the main character a shot
you know because josie has just now been
locked down now i feel like he knows
what he's doing
i can't think of much he hasn't tried
already with josie now that's that's
that's one of the main reasons why i
would say switch okay he's gone back to
hammerhead
you have to respect it
they must have paid a lot for him to
stay away from playing his main so much
i'll be i've been told that mob is very
very very good against convincer so he's
ready he knows what he has to do
[Music]
i don't know how i feel about this
though
[Music]
nice block with the wall bonkers and the
punish
both of them showing great defense being
20 seconds of them both pressing buttons
and they haven't lost a lot of a lot of
health really
okay this is a great start right now for
bumblebee that's the float though and
that was we've seen so many crazy stuff
in this that was last
all right where is your spent
i said there's a manager
and this is the string and oh that was
just a complete mix up there but
bumblebee guess is wrong and mob is just
storming through this reset right now
he's five rounds away from winning the
whole tournament oh that was no nice and
this up
oh
that punishes the art blast could have
been more
all right nice pull over kick
on back
trade which one gets the count here very
nice
now he's got some pressure he needs this
oh guaranteed follow up there nice bum
will be on the board again
okay he stopped the bleed that was very
important it's looking like he was
starting to get away from him
nice
and he gets a nice chunk and a throw
after very nice and deep
punish he's to use this wall
i have to respect mob's usage of that
low considering how it lost him around
earlier he just hasn't been deterred no
not at all not at all and to to give
away the frames and just stand there
after and see what he does very very
smart
very nice there from bumblebee the
regular throw broken
oh converts it again he's seen it all
the keychain
one for two
rage available for both now once before
no dark
war bongos nice block
brace spent
oh my goodness 20 seconds they're both
on such low health downfall rage
[Music]
oh he's getting
three
poor choice probably just felt like he
was going to go over standing through
there probably you could just feel it i
wasn't sure no i punished it on the art
blast
punishing cd3 though
this is crucial this is either two zip
or one all yeah this is a very important
game right now
i'm back
one
finishes the string again
bumblebee could take this round rage
span and nice that was gonna respect the
unblockable actual x and hot kick there
from bombing were tied up he is not out
of this yet
why does she cry like that
i'm not gonna even spend the rest of
commentary deciding about what's the
best character pick or stage pick i'm
done
i'm not doing it anymore
that was um
i don't know i know we want to see that
i feel like the queen of myths to pick
here but josie's staying alive josie's
still doing the job that he needs it to
do but you know that was with the walls
in play now now mob is going to go back
to his traditional i like no walls
there's going to be no walls in play
josie loses all that damage that she
gets with it all the wall carry it
doesn't mean anything
um
but we'll just see it was seeing some
great outplay here for more but
bumblebee is staying alive that hot kick
but that was just that was really good
there just the awareness and space of
mine so even a defensive situation be
ready to push a button like that to
counteract he was ready so that was a
good job
um and we're all tied up after the
bracket reset so you know bumblebee
keeping this close mob isn't going to
storm through this one today
no not at all and that that hopkin
wasn't like it was a panic button like
he's i don't think he's pressed that all
game like that was a clear active
decision to to interrupt it and it was
clutch especially after that round
before where they both
oh i mean god that was so close i nearly
gave me a heart attack there's the
infinite sure
smart decision as we know it's what it's
known for
it is indeed had a very very very high
success rate at this stage
watch your ankles watch your ankles
again this time he blocks it nice punish
come back back
and there it is switch one guess i can't
hit again
nice the war bunkers spaced it correctly
that's guaranteed of only the low hits
momentum swings once again it's a bumble
bee and that is such a bold decision
not going to get much on an infinite
stage off a low parry but that is such a
confident move
nice no that's not the punishment minus
12.
[Music]
be trying to force something here but
the g-clef kind of stops him completely
punish that
[Music]
nice dark
those two are broken
[Music]
i'm just stuffing him right now rage
drive
cd three
stepping
standing three and just like that bumpy
one more round he goes up two one of a
mob he looked he looked almost defeated
after the bracket reset but it's not
done in the back
in harada's name did he win that round i
i don't get it i don't get it that was
so good i think i think we might see mob
panicking a bit i think at the end he
tries to orbital that didn't work out
any three
okay nice guess the launch this is big
here for mob he needs this round
oh and running three just beating the
cd3 that's a huge statement it's such a
beautiful v3 as well
nice duck
oh no trash
microscope
did you be nice and punish there by mob
i've never seen that before
great low parry by bumblebee but no rage
so no extra damage does he stop him
before the rage
well inadvertently did
oh the new rage driver that's just just
people just aren't ready to see that
yeah i feel like
yeah that new race drive outside of
entry
it doesn't get you trunks but it's good
end again great blocker on the cd3
is mob gonna make this comeback it was
looking like he was down and out but
it's completely ready right now
on back
and mob is now
one more game and he is your evil
stephen
right sorry your evil eu east champion
will also be your toc eu east champion
that i've just been commentating mob too
much recently
you just totally option selected
yourself it was fun
[Laughter]
what a player
too much um but yeah because this is
exactly what superhuman did he was the
evo eu west champion and then he went on
to win toc and it's looking like mob is
going to do the same thing and supreme
also did that from this racket and the
same thing might happen here um but you
know i'm i'm really um
i'm really impressed by the way
bumblebee is playing with the josie
right now that we were both expecting a
switch at some point but sticking with
the josie playing well uh keeping it
competitive he could have won that game
there just came down to mob mob just
flicked the switch out of nowhere and it
just made things a lot more difficult
but i feel like you can still bring it
back
um
but yeah this is this could be the final
game if mob is uh
some point here
it's a legit josie i almost would feel
sad if he's changed now
we're gonna find out very shortly
drumroll josie on hammer okay
good choice good choice
and is this going to be our final game
of the tournament
oh these guys are going to twist it
again let's find out i mean i like it i
like you stuck with the jersey all the
way through i had a game plan it's
worked this far got him this far but mob
could end it all right here right now
i stuck
oh the full crowd swipes three in a row
into the g club cannon mob is on form
right now g clef cannon again this is
gonna be the first round for lmg mob
just took a sip from my drink and a
whole round went what the hell
and you see immediately bumpy is trying
to counteract that aggression trying to
get something in his own style there it
is yeah the switch starts going but oh
guess floated when you tried to do uh
ford one plus two going to the wall as
well shoulder splat
no goes for the mixed up regulator
broken
142 counter hit mob
okay but the gap three
needed that so bad
[Music]
again since that first time he hasn't
blocked it again but rage available for
pokemon the rage drive for bomb will be
he stays alive
that was crucial he was nearly
fighting against game game set
tournament round now it's one all
as the momentum has shifted in
bumblebee's favor big for one plus two
to start off with
[Music]
this is a great round right now from mob
has the live feed much pressure
i'm beating rage running three two
good break
[Music]
oh no while setting two into the back
stance
he needs to do so much now oh this is
the start though raise drive guaranteed
after that makes a full combo to the
wall makes up cds
the risk there from bumblebee he stays
alive and it all came from that forward
one plus two
that was a heroic comeback what a
comeback in conversion
how is he two rounds to one up after the
start of this game
that's crazy that's the float showed up
goes for the big low
[Music]
patience by bomb bcd three
[Music]
nice block on the wall one goes but
doesn't punish
patience
like four or four big range that's weird
punish finishes again that string and
just like that mob is on tournament
point with your toc eu east champion
bumblebee is being too passive right now
he's just watching mob he's watching mob
he's just watching him right now i think
he needs to do something
on back regular throw broken
cd through great block bumblebee enrage
the
he gets him
what a way to end the tournament there
by mob the air throw bumblebee wasn't
ready completely stylish exactly how you
want to end it stomps in him for good
measure and just like that mob is going
to be your toc eu east champion
i was enjoying that so much well done
tomorrow i didn't want it to end
bumblebee mob you played so so well what
a tournament 77 players from all over
the eu he's culminated in these two guys
going at it and look at it there
lmg mob our champion of the day
from uh evo to toc
uh the second player in europe to do it
mob and uh super cool will be very happy
with their performance in the both those
players will also be going to vegas as
well so great to see them uh continue
their form as well leading up to that
but what are showing by everyone here
today everyone had a great show i think
strog vs lmg mob was one of my favorite
games of the day um but bomby's josie
really surprising really caught me off
guard i didn't expect it we saw some
great things there like just staying in
the game you know times it looked like
he was down and out that we saw that in
that final game just managed to come
back used the race drive very well
standing three look at the movement down
four four just mixed up mob looked like
he could have taken it before the reset
he really did i mean it honestly could
have gone anyway this josie just grew
into the set as we went along
again people picking
their secondary characters and they're
not even a pocket character they are
fully developed i mean i don't even know
if he's his secondary he just played so
well with him
um and it just came down to the smallest
little things and and mob had to throw
the kitchen sink at him yeah
definitely a strong stream between both
to work so hard and it's interesting to
see a grand fan between josie and lars
you do not see that every single day
um and just that ending there but i do
oh the effort it looks so cool it is
breakable i don't know bumblebee knew
that because you got hit by it twice
but that was uh that was a we had a
great clc here today dude
let's take a look at where that puts
yeah when it puts the players
yeah no surprises there lmg mob sits in
first place bombay second greetings
third strong fourth
um the only players who didn't really
like the comey and friend and dropped in
the comey didn't have a great showing
for the rest of those players in this
top eight were the top eight that we had
here today
um so it's that you just see how how
that impacted the impacts of standing so
great showing from where today
congratulations to mob everyone you know
i was i i thoroughly enjoyed my time
here uh contain
me too me too uh it's been an absolute
pleasure and uh to see players from
playing all over eastern europe such as
turkey greece russia poland
and bulgaria has been absolutely
fantastic and please do make sure you
follow us online at all of our socials
that's bne esports on twitter b esports
on youtube tekken twitter tech and
twitch and of course tech and facebook
yeah shout outs about it now i'm going
to say before the action that they're
bringing us toc this year has definitely
been hype uh uh that is that is all it
for europe as well east and the us has
been done next stop tomorrow is going to
be west africa i believe i will be there
contain that as well i'm very excited to
see the players over there i'm looking
forward to seeing skywalker i've heard
great things about his law i've seen
some great things so uh you guys i hope
you will tune in for that one as well uh
bumble any final words for the people
no i just thank you for the amazing
tekken and look please attend your
masters events you can see how many
points you can pick up you can
completely blow up the leaderboard with
one good top eight so please do attend
and please do make sure you check out uh
the upcoming streams i'm looking forward
so much to west africa it's just gonna
be a lot of fun
yep so thank you everyone that watched
thank you to bumble for joy it's been a
while since we've done this together it
was definitely a pleasure and an honor i
hope you guys enjoyed seeing a bomb why
i always enjoy my time commentating with
this man
um i hope you guys enjoyed the tekken
hope you guys enjoyed the stream shout
outs production for all their hard work
and that backup stream we do not forget
you know that that was amazing uh thank
you all for watching we'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
[Music]
reality
[Music]
um
[Music]